what I'll get that title belt to for
guests hear me oh yeah we uh give you a
warranty the belt we should make your
belt you know any freaking mooks I had
to talk to him the [ __ ] web to
[ __ ] get that [ __ ] alright ladies and
gentlemen Brian the kid count is on set
so I set sent out the bat signal we up
to 2017 guest of the year feel Vaughn up
in the house
Gucci gang son Gucci carrying even text
Gucci kick me out here dude it's good to
be hey man this is the gayest little
microphone it feels like it's all up in
your grill Oh feels like a walk like I'm
the weakest one arm blackhead is trying
to give me a hug feels like you're like
like whoa somebody feed this boy and
then bring him back to the hug ring you
know cuz he ain't ready for [ __ ] real
too long this dude ain't ready hug him
with one arm he's not ready you don't
want to sit and Brian can't see it's
full too close and they slowly start
turning you can I can tell when I first
came here they're a little more
straighter and then over the years I
just keep this brighter y'all [ __ ]
just morph into one idiot
the bright one be closed for whatever
reason so yeah I feel like I'm in
business class like the whole time but
thanks for Emma and thanks for eating me
up and thanks for um thanks for having
me in yeah I guess the year man yeah
deal that was exciting dude that was
exciting and I am edged out Chris D'Elia
barely yeah his fans are not happy
probably not some hate where they you
know it goes yeah they call him daddy oh
they do yeah yeah that's gonna end in
court it's been going on man show last
night yeah I had a show last night oh
yeah thanks for voters man thanks your
listeners and uh and the people who
voted that is nice of them
so horse appreciate it you killed it one
coming in here you did the work
shoot last night Tommy still have to
cancel man just under the weather and I
leave for Portland tomorrow I just had
to get better I had to get better eyes
hoping I'd see you did lineup was insane
man yeah y'all's lineup upstairs is
really good notes
it looked like you look like you're
holding water in the face a little bit
yeah a little bit are you a little I'm
sure are you on creatine no no no maybe
just Carvin creatine uh-uh
you just have a stepdad he was in the
war right and he made my sister get on
creatine because he was real lazy dude
he thought it was gonna help with like
laziness so he was just lazy and [ __ ]
on creatine he just get all bloated yeah
but it didn't help anything
she said honestly their message is
pretty wild huh she got well she got she
said she felt like her body turned into
a water bed that's when she's fit
because she was as I guess is holding
water does hold water and she would
sleep more than you know yeah that so we
kind of did the opposite just that
comfort yeah you've been on that
creatine oh yeah when it first came out
dude
it was a big deal may not hide that [ __ ]
in my ass kids were doing anything for
it and when it first came out yeah
creatine is a big deal I ran a grape
flavor I'm not cheap yeah uh it's like
40 50 bucks to get Jack no water Jack
they call honor Jack yeah that water
smoke oh yeah you could cut somebody and
[ __ ] and uh feed your plants you know
you said last night at The Comedy Store
ago he was okay I think they had some
people from Netflix that were out so you
know you yeah I think just come in and
supposed to come out you know so I think
I had a little bit of nerves up top
you know speaker so did your agent
manager or they like you know tonight at
the Comedy Store Netflix come to see you
perform yeah
yeah when they were supposed to come
right for the holidays and they couldn't
sit and they came you know allegedly
came last night but yes I was a little
bit nervy up top you know and I wish I
would have been but then once I settled
in I was real comfortable once you hit
the stage you're good right yes before
no I think right when I hit the stage
I'm a little nervous I think my nerves
come from the fact that I feel like
things are so like a lot of these a lot
of executives and stuff are so like not
liberal but just so like one way that
you can't even like you can't even joke
you don't know offend them yeah it's
like I feel like no matter what they're
gonna see it as offensive even if it's a
lot of what I do is satire so it just
spooks me a little however Dave
Chappelle's special but help
yeah you know like Netflix and let that
fly you should be alright yeah that's
true it's a good point but then I feel
like some comedians are grandfathered
into that where it's like if you're at a
certain you know you're already at a
certain status then you
yeah then you can live yeah you can say
whatever you want I think you're a good
man I think they would need something
like you you know I'm saying you would
think do but I think they also want to
just you know a lot of they just want to
keep putting MOOCs on and just piss
everybody in the rest of America off
until people start fighting you know
maybe so you were just like tents could
cuz sometimes what happened to me like I
did this thing for the Golden Globes oh
yeah on the red carpet yeah I saw your
shoes on yours yeah thanks Doug
but I was a little nervous before that
I'm like why am i nervous man this isn't
it doesn't make sense whenever I would
be I was nervous for you bruh I really
was like dude this guy's gonna [ __ ] it
up no I was no I've never worried about
that it's just I don't know I I don't
know if it's nerves or sometimes I think
people get confused nerves and
excitement right like I was excited to
do the show yeah but then like I've been
seeing that because I'm my big show and
boss in the Wilbur theater this is like
god I hope I don't [ __ ] it up well why
would I [ __ ] it up right I've done this
show how many times yeah I have new bits
in it but I've done how many white and
I've never messed up one why would you
even plant that seed it makes zero see
that's a good point yeah maybe I'm
playing some of those scene myself you
know I just wish that I could figure out
why some things are going to and I do
not have nerves and other things that go
into and they do show up did you care
about it
yeah because you want Netflix yeah yeah
maybe that's it you should be on there
for sure maybe cuz I care about it you
know let's choose what happens that's a
good thing though I'm sure you did good
yeah it's true yeah I did good but I
just want to do perfect you know but
yeah man that red carpet what they have
you guys do it was like a panel so we
had to we watched the the award show and
then we were the after-show
so we'd have like celebrities come it
was just a pan of me in like three
fashion and celebrity experts were you
did you say a lot of stuff or yes kind
of chill oh wow I was brave II did I was
really scared sometimes before you talk
I'm just I just have to remind myself
like don't don't cuss it's
oh you know this is whatever I'll cuss
whatever oh yeah but then also they
threw a wrench in there like oh do you
know how to be prompt driving a red
prompter in my life like yeah no doubt
cool you take your lead on promptly okay
let's do that and it's in wing-dings van
Gogh did sometime they'll sneak a wild
fauna attach it to that prompter do or
it'll go real slow and you're like come
on man so yeah that's where that's where
it messed me up cuz went almost too slow
oh yeah sometimes I might be right back
from the red carpet here they going what
you know so know that they get a
prompter if like one of those
mental-health facility to something
where somebody they have a lot of mental
people that are in there yeah that's
when they read until oh yeah they'll get
bootleg ones that are cheaper and how
you save money is the people that are
using them are mentally handicapped and
so then you get this you gotta study
they only on that one speed I'm taking
the New Orleans st.
shirt man yeah man they're into it do we
got a job to do yeah I think the coaches
on pills I think he's on percocets but
why's that you know apparently you can
coach an NFL team on them sets money
they kind of run themselves as a head
coach you're like your old coordinator
Andy coordinator doing everything yeah
kind of I can't even a met like I think
Belichick is like a real coach you know
uh yeah kind of and then after that I
feel like it kind of follows all the
strategist and then you have the often
scorned in a defense coordinator call
natural plays but then with the head
coach once you get that level off so you
know what you're doing once you get that
level it's like y'all fourth and short
should we go for it that's it's called
yeah dude I would love to see us two
dudes [ __ ] uh I saw two homeless not
dudes one of them could have been a
woman making out yesterday actually when
I was on um what is that Robertson
really yes two homeless dudes making out
could have I think a woman was a woman
but had kind of short hair it's tough to
tell yeah I was going pretty fast you
know he just kept on keeping on oh I can
gender eyes a homeless person at about
ten miles probably anything over that
it's up in the air it's anybody's
ballgame like food but yea they were
making out dude so well yeah yeah I come
by where I trained cuz there's this box
there's like this alleyway and I saw two
bums male bums jacking each other ah
yeah a little morning wood
oh yeah whole morning hand job doing I
was growing up I don't know if I told
the story here but they used to have you
know they have this rest area you know
where a lot of men would meet and
drug-induced homosexuality would occur
you know I'm not talking straight-up
natural homosexuality I'm talking
drug-induced
meaning you're on drugs and then you're
gay yeah you know you're only gay when
you're on drugs
yeah weird so because that's a lot of
that's a baaad that's a side effect of a
lot of drugs you know and they don't put
that on the little bags ever that you
might meet a buddy with a chat you know
and uh and so this some they had these
dudes that would shoot a lot of men
would meet up on this rest of you do
drugs and then coagulate you know do the
thing
yeah do all kinds of things and stuff
and so sometimes we would sit across
because I live across where I live to
back up to this river where you could
see across to the rest here and the rest
areas but behind the interstate so
there's a river between me and the
interstate and then between the river
and the interstate is the rest area
where and so we'd get one time we go
down there and there's these dudes man
these two big guys that are shooting
potatoes across this river with a potato
gun they have binocular it's Louisville
petunia anytime like two fellows would
get a little too quick in suits you will
they [ __ ] fire a Todd over at him
there's a process real haters man the
[ __ ] blockers I am welcoming [ __ ] block
yeah we didn't know what they were doing
we're like what are you guys doing and
they're like we're firing these tots
over at these boys over their own dope
and so he's not looking Tots to stop
this game so we start looking through
the binoculars and look man I mean uh
yeah anybody should be able to have sex
with anybody they want 100% dude I'll
[ __ ] your cousin bro but what I'm saying
is I'll [ __ ] your cousin Blanco and
blindfolded dude all in before the deal
all right all right
so whatever bro maybe he's gay I'm not
but what I'm saying is that the the that
it doesn't matter but these guys were
intent on
japanese fellows but if they just hugged
or anything no tot but they started to
quicken if one of them started going if
they started it was really almost a
vertical issue once they started getting
a little too horizontal you can tailor
time yeah
can't even taught it up and they went on
lunch break and and we got to take over
me and my buddy firing these tossed it
we can only shoot them like to the
middle of the river though oh so then
you saw but it was fun is it kind of
like a Civil War Reenactment a little
bit a little bit yeah it had that vibe
you know kind of but anyway I'm just
saying that yeah that kind of stuff that
kind of stuff goes on man you know were
we talking about you had some friends
shooting tater tots a gay guys there
were friends of mine do they were locals
big difference man my buddies when I
don't think they would do that well we
did do it on lunch break but that's just
you didn't hit him use you just it's
just fun to fire me saw potato gun we
were the halftime show
Oh at college really yeah people used to
he was just shoot him across like like
one apartment complex had a bunch and
another apartment complex and have a
bunch and they would just shoot him in
here to go to school
Louisiana State over in University of
Arizona actually as well but people just
launched them you know this potato or
they were like rocket launchers it's
kind of dangerous
yeah oh it's [ __ ] vegetable Isis out
there there if you want show it's
dangerous man dude I saw I do pull up
one time just stop hitting me fire off
to [ __ ] tots it's like you know get
back into a car [ __ ] it Jeff don't even
over they win dude they're [ __ ] hard
ya hit by a date again no ever Wow it
[ __ ] you up
you seem like someone would get shot at
I agree chin looks like looks like a bad
guy from an 80s movie dawg you got a
sound we're a minute now um you do use
the leather jacket rolled up yeah first
day I wear a leather jacket to I'm not
gonna oh wow yeah how do you feel in it
cuz I feel different in different types
of coats
I always feel the same yeah I wear
sweats all the time I always feel the
same when I dressed up in like a leather
jacket you feel different do you seem
different that thing yeah a little cocky
though yeah does little cocky in it seem
like Dan what the [ __ ] is that
yeah you know I agree even though I know
him yeah you called him a dream yeah
yeah you call him the dream that [ __ ]
yellow dream it's a Korean Korean dream
hey yo hey scream flavor do Korean dream
bro I agree the Koreans are full of
dreams man yeah we saw this Asian guy
could have been Korean he was fell off a
building when he hit the bottom huh
dreams came out of him bro but dreams
doing guts and blood no I just mean you
could just feel the [ __ ] fragments of
ideas open imagination fly out of his
body
we're talking about being on podcast and
he said we're talking about Rogge and I
said you were on there for three hours
so he said I never talked anyone for
three hours
yeah man will join I didn't know he we
didn't know each other you know and I
was the first that's the first time
you've had a conversation with him I
think so yeah so I did not brought some
oranges over there and uh because
somebody said he likes you know somebody
said he liked fruits and vegetables so I
brought some I had some what are those
tangerines or tangelos out of sack at
Angelo's at the house and yeah it's
offering some tangelos yeah brought what
I had you know yeah but we think about
it when's the one's the last time you
talked to someone for three hours
oh I've never talked to somebody nice
hole I see some girl on the phone you're
not talking to people for on the phone
for three hours not even in court not
even in a relationship never that's why
podcast is Sony kind of me yeah I see
you at the Comedy Store we rap I mean
two out of this thing you know you know
hour and a half two hours oh we talked
until Brian shows up in [ __ ] ruins a
conversation dude but yeah that was the
first time and I never talked to anybody
for three hours in the whole life dude I
told him that on the show anyway would
you why would you talk I mean not even
if I was married dude if I ever I think
they should have like you know word
limits on spouses
you know like Oh like it weird a month
almost like Twitter yeah yeah yeah like
kinda four senses in a day nice Oh
Judy's got about foursomes loud better
use it why go ahead and make it count
gonna be a quiet spring
hey guys come over barb already used up
holler words but that would be now you
know I think in the future we'll have
stuff like that man you think dude I was
thinking yesterday about virtual reality
right and I was thinking because to me
one of the biggest problems in America
is you have people that just live in
different universes right like I would
never like by a lot of people run from
or gun owners you know and they want
guns and they're like guns you know and
here people are like no way you know no
gun or a liberal yeah yeah so but I get
it like yeah would you have a gun in
[ __ ] Beverly Hills dude [ __ ] no bro
it would weigh you down it would look
weird in your pants right oh you're
talking about concealing a weapon yeah
at well yeah I mean at home it makes
sense right to have a gun at home yeah
it's a little different because you're
protecting your home you'll be won't be
Walker Texas Ranger with a gun in your
pocket baby that's always weird - maybe
what could happen people like carry guns
yeah makes me nervous but but even just
to have a gun or to see guns around in
Beverly Hills be crazy crazy but then
you go to like you know you go to New
Orleans and not to have a gun not that
crazy
you know to have a gun in your truck I
have a gun sitting there have a gun no I
find the South right he had the South
the Midwest us - yeah Texas love they
really like to have gone you know like
taking their guns dude they had a guy i
remember like 15 years ago they'd try to
install a [ __ ] rifle and it was he
had lost an arm doing something you know
you're making like a Robocop would just
a yeah
dude he lost it over you and something
crazy I think somebody threw something
he tried to catch it with something
heavy he was already like on a raft or
something and it just took his arm off
damn you know like somebody threw some
idiot threw him something real heavy and
he grabbed it and caught it but then it
just kept going ran his are yeah [ __ ]
and then what he caught it
he caught it that's the good point but
um they're gonna turn that into a k4y
trying to get a rifle God even like it
apparently got in touch with the right
for the you know Smith & Wesson on one
of these companies and tried to get him
to install a rifle and it was bunk
that'd be sick super sick they dope
super dope how did your last surgery
still rocking it the dog that knows
surgery last time I got the hair I know
you got the hair the hair looks good
it's coming in well here's the thing the
the I got some mullet taken out of the
back and put into the front right here
on the rim yeah I'm not mad at that
on this cuss but you've never had a
issue it's not like you were losing your
hair now I just want that front mullet
all right that words nobody's got that
he had a nose job no I didn't have a
nose job dude I'll take one if you want
to put money in like a GoFundMe for a
nose yeah he's so crazy if I'd actually
be too weird but I couldn't breathe that
night when I would go to sleep at night
my nose I couldn't breathe less and less
you were one of those strips like an
[ __ ]
oh I'd wear three of them they don't
want to work bro they worked for me
daily oh well I'd [ __ ] feel like I
was calming some justcome was just
building up and they're just huddling up
in the back of my head so you'd use
those they'd open up your Airways yeah I
can feel how good it feels right now
with those things on cuz you got to do
three though you got to have one on the
regular and you got to have two at the
slaw not build a bridge oh dude you got
a you got to have a friend of Georgia
Tech to help you out I've got a
blueprint you got to go on playing yeah
it's good do it right oh and some in the
Deep Web there's different ways you can
really get your breath breathing really
just open yeah well you would you have a
deviated septum no I just had some
[ __ ] who knows man you know I don't
know what happened there man said I
could've got hit by something I remember
somebody threw something at me once but
it knocked me out on him and what it was
Dan I remember what else happened dude
fell into something that was made out of
cement one time a great I had stone
we're jumping on different headstones at
the graveyard when I was young
[ __ ] took one of the dome dude that
might do it yeah it took a
seventy-year-old
right to the darling boy and um what
else happened but I don't know but I
felt like the devil was trying to choke
me out at night because it would get
less and worse nothing worse and so he
said you did or didn't have surgery so I
went in and they put you under I thought
you're just gonna stop in now you can't
just stop in to fix the nose and I'm
like yeah you need nose too yeah and
they went in they went in there you know
when that man got in there and I was
asleep you know which I think's a little
[ __ ] up I'd rather be awake and see
who is in there you don't want to be
away from that said
you know these people it's true you
don't know get inside your body where
you're asleep dude it's illegal its
assault brother yeah yeah so when I was
worried about was uh you know just what
would happen and I went in there and he
said it was a mess when they get in
there and they like shaved down like
parts that are way up in here in the top
you don't see anything you couldn't
notice it but he said there was a lot of
scar tissue in here that they could cut
and like and like and just stuff like
that back in fact how long ago was that
dude I blew a [ __ ] bat wing out of
one of my nose as one morning dude it
was a booger that honestly way after the
surgery Oh a gold miner what turned it
in for cash brother this thing was huge
gelatinous yes it looked like an embryo
for so after the surgeries and yeah dude
I had no surging they have to put
brackets in my nose really then that
these stitches to keep the brackets in
yeah cuz I shattered my nose all sorts
of places from a fight from a fight I
was the worst the worst so I'm on
painkillers get an addiction addicting
painkillers after the nose surgery but
then they went in I had these back to my
nose for weeks and weeks and weeks then
I come here I take him out and I was so
scared for them take them out and they
they just snip the stitches and pull it
in like this thing like this big comes
out and it felt so glorious oh oh it
felt nice yeah like a candle coming out
like a big old candle how to make it
spray out there's glory it's kind of
wild of different ways you could really
come if people really could master the
use of different canals in their body
agree you know like that was damn near
close to the sex organs dude I took a
big dump on ecstasy one time it almost
came I see I've heard that before though
and that's pretty wild you know it's a
little scary did you make you feel a
little homoerotic like you can feel the
squirrels run a little no no but do you
mean yeah it makes you feel you know
like you like men might be trying to get
to know you
yeah I think but what else man we're
talking with MJ she just got back from
Europe and I would you went to Amsterdam
I said you saw the girls there she
got her phone taken because they're
trying they're trying to film the girls
oh really
you just kid do not her no in the
red-light district yeah my friend took
my phone to take a photo of me like
confirm of the girls and this girl came
out and like almost like attack doesn't
act like took my phone away yeah it's a
known thing I thought like you're not
supposed to take photos my friend like
insisted on it is there signs saying no
pics oh it could be in Dutch I don't
read Dutch yeah I'm gonna be like yeah
like a hooker beating a woman yeah yeah
like your girl taking pictures are you
sign or something my mother also you're
a girl if you were a hooker do you think
you'd what well maybe it's part of the
culture like people love it I guess
that's a way to look at it have you have
you ever been Amsterdam yeah I feel like
you get in some weird [ __ ] in the
incident we were to a set shot took my
girlfriend over there and we went and
watched this sex show and it was the
main stars were out I guess it was like
a flu going around and said they had
some real third stringers on the wheel I
can water boy and his and his female
cousin in there you know I mean this is
something your country probably ate
these people Kenya but here's what I'm
saying is that it was like a lazy susan
right and so you get in these little we
get in a little room that are all around
this lazy susan and your little room has
a window that face what's a lazy susan a
lazy susans like a thing that spins
around the grandmother had like if you
open her drawer okay you know you're in
it yeah
so there's windows all around this lazy
susan yeah there's windows all around
this lazy susan and you go in and you
get your little booth and you can go
stand in there and watch it through your
window to see the lady's disease so you
can see a few other people kind of
vaguely who are in their window you
can't see them doing like jacking off in
them you can't see them but you can
guess that they're probably jacking off
okay and then you can see it a little
bit in your head imagination
yeah then what was going on on the show
I was in there oh it's too [ __ ] I
mean it was like the guy could barely
even [ __ ] it was like he had just one
like a [ __ ]
drawing somewhere that he'd never
thought he would win you know but he did
all the entries and it was like it was
[ __ ] somebody like he knew he wasn't
supposed to be [ __ ] you know
like the first couple times like you
ever peer here yourself but you don't
put it all the way through the first
time you just kind of keep checking for
where it's okay that cos is too bro it
was like you just try to figure it out
on the fly working the freelance working
freelance man was the girl who's not hot
Oh a girl was not hot brown and then
here's the crazy thing denna didn't want
to watch him [ __ ] no I wouldn't do you
think you have to stay in your little
cage until the daily finishes are the
rules oh no you just have to stay in
there until like its until like there's
a certain amount of time I think it's
three minutes and you get in there
before your door open oh thank you so
then you're like locked in and watching
these people [ __ ] dude and it's almost
it got harrowing man I was like I was
like cheering at first for kind of for
somebody and then I wasn't and then I
was like it's like me you don't wanna
watch the game anymore yeah you're over
it again turn the [ __ ] off was your girl
feeling it I think she was due but she
and I had a tough go out there in Europe
my eyes just like traveling around and
we'd have a lot of money so we're doing
it
it was a while ago yeah this probably
about nine years ago oh [ __ ] and we're
you know we're traveling around you know
backpacking and staying like Pam out at
campgrounds and [ __ ] like that you know
it's [ __ ] cheap dude you know and so
we're staying out of campgrounds a shed
like morning mist and like other
tourists were saying we were saying like
we're local poor people were we got the
really crazy but she probably hated it
I was Rocky man it was rock because are
you all the time out there oh we almost
got arrested at this grocery store day
she was beating me with [ __ ] frozen
items with semi-frozen little first
precinct as deep as we do yeah yeah we
waste a lot of electricity freeze and
stuff real deep over here we freeze to
deep I agree with that I've always
thought that man you go in there some of
that [ __ ] it's too much we don't need
this song her keys you're like what the
[ __ ] frozen I'm solid like what they did
is dazed oh yeah but they do yeah
want to read the backstory on this thing
to see if he deserved this because
they'll have those birds it's
unbelievable yeah man so that you and
that girl did when you got back did you
break up with her yeah I remember oh I
remember the last moment really of our
relationship was she I was at the bottom
of one of those um you know moving
staircases escalators and she pushed the
[ __ ] luggage we had where one of
those smart carts
yeah and I was yelling something from
the bottom and she just pushed that
[ __ ] right down the escalator
spicy spicy yeah why girl yeah yeah
pretty white man and they uh and that
was it man when he got back though you
find out a lot about someone on a long
trip
yeah and I met her I was the problem I
may be I'm sure it's both maybe just
didn't mix fried get to good people just
didn't mix so she it's stressful no
money you travel around Europe even
watch this this mutant [ __ ] this other
thing didn't help the cause wasn't a
fine it was bad zine of the it was like
went rounds in the Giants played a bomb
it's a waste of time Jesus Christ it's
not even raining and they're playing
like it's in the rain oh but yeah man
wild uh I had a wild holiday man had
some pheasant or something if you read
that no I don't need a lot of gave me
food yeah
rody and Brian talk all day about
pheasant yeah would you go back home you
know went back to Louisiana and it was
you know I've never been anything up in
the dark are it's like a PDF file or
anything like that and I don't believe
in that kind of [ __ ] if anybody's out
there doing that shut it down but I
don't what is it PDF files oh yeah
dudes a party with children yes and but
I'll say this do when you have if you're
eating pheasant dude there's a party
when you crack it into this little thing
you're like this is this even what God
wanted for us have you ever had have
you've had him come on guy
I'm surprised to know they no doubt dude
to need sushi from
the house yeah you don't know it's a
baby bird yeah man it's something it
just was killed early it seems like you
know we're talking about that
that's veal too right yeah it feels the
same thing that just doesn't seem right
to me yeah yeah they don't what let's
don't let it move and then let's [ __ ]
eat it God it's wrong and you're eating
the hips and butt of it really yeah it's
so [ __ ] okay
that man is the regular beef not good
enough for a man it's just too much when
you cuz this little thing you have to
like move its legs and I love it so and
the legs like cut won't fall off in your
hand like throwing it up and catch it
kind of savages made pheasants people
call this hippie yeah we have people in
Mississippi man they'll eat anything out
there dude they'll [ __ ] eat anything
I had a friend of Mines aunt died out
there a turtleneck she got at war a
tight total night for like nine days in
a row and it cut off her [ __ ]
windpipe and killed her like this is the
tightest turtleneck of all time wasn't
that tight but she wasn't that strong
she was getting older it was like
overtime and she didn't change your
shirt so a lot of that's on her you know
yeah who's the blame here you know I'm
saying well they tried to sue the
company
what was the who made that [ __ ] bum
equipment with that nag boy that's a
fragile instrument you know did Stussy
make your [ __ ] turn I don't like to
come back though they're back they're
back as killers dude
yeah the silent killer is no longer
emphysema son it's that [ __ ]
turtleneck dude you were for eight days
and then it shut er down boy ah do me it
was just her time to go you know if a
turtleneck get you out of there it's
probably go time yeah then God wants you
you know bonus you got going on them
just try and get on Netflix just doing
your comedy thing yeah good yeah podcast
this past weekend is going good we just
got our highest listenership last week
it's really good we got 23,000 episode
22 thousand listeners perhaps
so on last week yeah I think it's our
highest one it's you and who else just
me so it's just me talking about like
basic life suggestions for struggling
males you know men that are out there in
the dark arts jerking off crying in
their truck and anything else you can
think of it's it's tough these days for
white males
oh yeah boy they were just yeah so
you're kind of a voice for them I don't
know man I don't even know and even know
what I'm talking about but you know I
feel like I'm just trying to share
what's going on you know I told you when
I when I was I told you said the Comedy
Store when I was in Buffalo I was
talking to the manager he's like dude
who should we bring in him like you guys
need a you gotta get Theo in here man oh
thanks man gotta get Theo down here all
the clubs like who's the funniest one
like you gotta get feelin this [ __ ]
thanks man you'd kill it man yeah I
appreciate you say I told ya I told
y'all for used to be from the J pilos my
new was quarterback up there that's
right and we used to go up there and he
was like the kids from Tulane yeah he
went to Tulane and uh he's funny and
actually went to school in Venice out
here in Los Angeles
dude he really yeah makes me like him
anymore yeah we used to be but he's a
nice guy I don't see him I wanna move to
New York and got into real estate after
the bills after the bills and right
before the stock market crash so who
knows he's really sound like could've
been a tough decade for you ago would
you go up to Buffalo and party with him
you guys gonna like bring yeah went up
there went up there we had a good time I
think I've been up there two times and
we had fun yeah it was just a neat
experiences to see somebody you know
like get to be a quarterback in the NF
I just met him at Tulane and um it would
just go hang out and stuff sometimes
who's he wild what was he like he was
athletic as all get-out no he was kind
of like a little bit of us just a basic
kind of guy you know not simple but just
basic and you'd like to kind of learn he
was kind of he liked to kind of learn I
think the NFL might have been from my
perspective might have been uh you know
I don't know if he knew how much of a
leader maybe supposed to be on a team
you know yeah such as the quarterback
yeah I'm for you to lead and maybe there
was already a lot of egos on that team I
think yeah and also it's [ __ ] Buffalo
who even knows what's going on
good I mean that place is a lot of neck
tattoos Rochester well you get over to
Rochester do you'll see ink on a woman's
neck out there you know so bad there's a
heavy looked a buffalo great food yeah
yeah yeah it's fun I wouldn't go in the
winter but outside that you should go
and you go into their stadium I never
their best fans I've ever seen I mean
it'll be below zero they'll have a dead
family member dude died of [ __ ]
frozen they just tie them to the truck
and go into the game they don't give a
[ __ ] on they start tailgating at 7:00
a.m. yeah the people at my in my crowd
were like oh we're off man we got you go
I'm like why like Bills game tomorrow
home game like alright cool like well we
start at 7:00 and it's Blizzard they
don't give a [ __ ] they different animal
brow fall to him so what's that stadium
called ruffled oh no stadium and they
love it man they love and then when the
bills got in the playoffs because
Cincinnati
Dalton when Dalton hello yeah I'll begin
the priority Andy throughout 70 yeah
dirty and the ginger the [ __ ] yeah the
red ginger Dalton help them get in the
playoffs so then the bills mafia donated
hundreds of thousands of dollars to yeah
yeah to help him keep playing yeah fun
me or I think it's his organization or
the [ __ ] it is yeah it's not crazy there
was another season for handy dog that
would be great if opposing teams got to
pay the salaries for the opponents it's
so [ __ ] up if they did cuz they're
just because they pay like the worst
player yeah yeah that idea that's a bad
idea you know who I saw this may be
thinking lows when the I was at a
meeting yesterday and yeah you know
caught the college football over at
Baker Mayfield yeah the Heisman for Ohio
say I'm sorry for Oklahoma yeah he just
lost a Georgia a big fan of him cuz use
a walk-on right was a walk at a Texas
Tech and he's a walk-in at Oklahoma's
first walk in after when the Heisman oh
I don't know how small he is so I'm
waiting for that for the elevator I'm
talking to finishing this meeting and
he's next to meet with these people I'm
meeting with and he atop the elevator
and they're like oh hey this is a Baker
Baba and I'm like oh what's up man
shakes in and I'm
my god what I know that you ever do I'm
like where I know that do ya
I'm trying to family where'd the [ __ ] do
I know him from my costumes driving me
nuts oh I scare you
hey where would I know that guy from
he's like you serious only K he's like
that's the Heisman winner man I'm like
that's him he's tiny
he's small probably the recognizes he's
white he's now small dude though he's
just yeah I couldn't believe how small
it was but really yeah but apparently
like hopefully you know and they do this
they did Johnny Manziel hoping he can be
like a frickin Drew Brees but good luck
with that yeah yeah that's true I wish
him the best I'm actually a big fan has
like the passion he plays when I like
that he was a walk-on but yeah it's
gonna be it's a tough go when you're
that size oh yeah man I remember when
Drew Brees came to New Orleans they had
I just been doing comedy maybe like two
years and I was buddies with this guy
Scott Fujita who was I don't Scott yeah
nice guy and he came out as dud yeah I
mean pretty handsome I did they gives
that handsome stud football player
oh my bad yeah but he um he brought drew
out to the comedy show one night and
drew just got into town literally was
signed like two days before like had
never even played and I got to meet him
after the show and he seemed like a nice
guy you know asked about comedy you know
a little bit it was just he wasn't the
star that he is now yeah you know
because he came from the charge ei come
from the Chargers but he like I was
bigger than him you know I mean this is
years ago thing right but I was like wow
this guy is gonna be the quarterback so
I think some people just have a real
special gift I think he has an amazing
work ethic breeze yeah and but also
talented thing Tommy like his release
everything his footwork he's so smart
yeah I agree and we we got to perform
for those I did some shows actually with
uh four performer for Oklahoma and
performing for Georgia before the Rose
Bowl really yep where'd you do that at
the improv one one team each different
night Pam really did I was intimidating
a Hollywood improv yeah where they died
I mean they were dying but when they
warrant it's like 19 to 22 year old boys
who when they're [ __ ] when they're
probably when they're you know having a
black you don't know like if somebody
one of them says something you'll know
about cuz yeah I'm like a [ __ ] you feel
like a senior citizen man that's what I
was talking with Bryan about this is so
where do you like you the people who are
like uber famous on YouTube and
Instagram and
and they have this young following like
yeah Selena Gomez the most followed on
Instagram whatever has like 40 million
followers flying followers but she's so
young and this young crowd came up with
it because all those kids aren't social
media yeah
so if you don't have like if you can't
figure out a way to relate to that young
crowd it's gonna be tough to compete
with those big stars man right you know
I'm saying so even with those college
kids but your material will relate to
them like you don't need to be yeah but
some reference some [ __ ] they just own
things cool you know well if you would
talk politics you're gonna lose them
yeah and if you talk for too long if
your sentences are too long you lose
them their attention spans like yeah
yeah I mean they would be going back
under the phones or disappea but it was
crazy like the Georgia team was way
wilder in the Oklahoma team was a little
was a lot more organized when they said
like we're in the place that's so it's
what we walked in and like the Georgia
teams on the stage like just rap
battling each other you know cuz they
they just got there before there was
some microphone all brothers - yeah I
mean these guys are going at Georgia
besides the quarterback yeah it is it
was like six white guys like a little
bit scared kind of towards the front
yeah and the quarterback I guess yeah
the freshman quarterback trying to not
[ __ ] it up for him but it was fun man it
was fun to just kind of be around those
guys but it was intimidating if there
were moments rob wasn't where I lost my
footing a little bit or even just a
couple of words cuz you'd it's just all
the losses yeah I'm gonna lose them
right yeah and it's all like tough dude
you don't even know how to do anything
but just [ __ ] do you have a membrane
where you just bombed you know when
you're bombing you got to dig yourself
out have you everyone ready don't get
out yeah I got to what to my crazy
members one time some dude laughed so
hard at the show he came out of the
closet to his buddies just writing for
them I swear to god he's like like
jarred some minutes in his stem you know
and his buddies like what [ __ ] it's
right about the front
you made him laugh so hard he just
admitted he's gay one of his buddies
spit milk or spill it on that milk beer
yeah you know oh yeah his buddies are
like what the [ __ ] didn't it was awkward
cuz it seemed kind of real yeah so me
and I've had people say a lot of stuff
II like that guy's [ __ ] but this guy
seemed like he might have been on a semi
sexual
and then the other time that I really
bombed was because I'm not trying to
[ __ ] you know bringing anybody the
other side of the sexual ledger you know
but the other time that I really had a
tough time I was at University of South
Florida or Central Florida one of the
other and people always like which one
was and I'm like well who gives a [ __ ]
which one was great no matter what
obviously I'm not in a cool city in
Florida but they brought me out and a
bomb dude bombed right in the begin i'd
been doing comic three years and i'm
bombed and it was this thing like
battled the bands for their school they
booed me off the stage it was like 800
people booed me some got booed me with
an american flag like i was an american
you know and i'm sure you've probably
dealt with some of this shitty time but
it's like some guy like waving an
American flag and booing you know did me
so yeah I'm just going backstage which
is still America you [ __ ] the Muppet
Betty do you like away well first I
thought he was supporting me this is the
worst part so I saluted him right even
though I was never in ROTC right and I
hated those [ __ ] dudes I didn't hate
him but it was like really a bunch of
just like [ __ ] closeted gay dudes at
our school that were running around
after school with wooden guns yeah and
you'd see him in the hallway like like
[ __ ] taking cover didn't mind some
lockers with wooden guns you're like
what the [ __ ] just and one of them I got
in trouble for sneaking a walkie-talkie
you know you know because they're not
supposed to have anything but wooden
guns just watching the cheerleaders
dance there does pervert but they had on
like uniforms you know misfits yeah so I
saluted - dude you know but this so then
it may it didn't but he was like against
me
yeah then I was like [ __ ] cuz then I was
like oh yeah we're buddies and he was
[ __ ] against yeah who doesn't know so
I had to go backstage what they didn't
know was I was in seeing the evening so
I had to come back out on a stage five
more times between each act and
introduce the next act every time you
came home with your boo-boo every time
until the fourth time it became so funny
that they were doing it every time that
then it like gave me a chance to like
get back in there grace
cool man like I'd been pushed so far
they're like [ __ ] and uh and by the
fourth time that became the gay a lot of
comedians especially this day and age
won't do colleges anymore
yeah I won't do um piss cuz you go to
like the thing and it would be this nuts
are much if like I'm monopolizing the
conversation not at all man please while
you're here but yeah you go there and
it's like some little dude or woman at
somebody who's gender-neutral and they
have you know a little bit of hair but
it's like kind of a mustache kind of a
like a woman's haircut yeah it's time
and it's like they have a couple of
diseases you haven't heard of and
they're perfectly round they're not even
any so it's like as long as you want to
fin them right and they're gonna die
soon which is gonna be tough yeah so
yeah a lot of comics won't do college
campuses anymore it's so freaking it's a
rough culture out there man
Oh Ben Shapiro is the only one you can
go in and do it I feel like you know
feel like D'Elia could do it yeah delete
could younger audience any is enough of
a fanbase if you have enough of a
fanbase you can go do it but if you're
going in there like we're just gonna
bring a comedian you are sitting Doug
bad idea those Black Panthers at a Shawn
went to one time and then even had this
was like 10 years going even have Black
Panthers you know it's just like dudes
who didn't have anything else to do what
it was asleep at the [ __ ] snack table
or whatever like I'm like [ __ ] that
thing's been euthanized brother you know
maybe you should join the Mexican
Student Union to just leave your buddy
there behind you know yeah I don't
college campus is a tricky one man it's
so stupid this one kid who's like
dressed up like a Native American you
know and he's like claiming all this
[ __ ] it's just so so weird I feel like
it's a weird time on college campuses
for kids like trying to figure it out
and try and find their way you can't
[ __ ] anybody you don't know anymore
yeah it's like when I was young I
remember fucking's people don't even
know who they are you know no I mean
yeah talk about college yeah and I do
like homeboy who's the comedian who got
busted lost his Shawn County Central
because a girl from college came out and
said he did so TJ Miller yeah I love TJ
they said he'd someone came out and was
like
a girl he was dating college on all the
facts so I don't you know yes I think
yeah she said he hid a bottle in her
butt or something like that cutter tooth
not a two-layer I don't think but
something one of those mid-range ones
you know she yeah not other one of this
little coke when do you get not well
like if you talk about xx oh yeah a 20
class against man that would get that's
a nervous winter DUI how about I don't
know if it's on your current events chin
but James Franco got busted with sexual
assault now yeah right after we won his
award this girl tweeted out but then she
since deleted the tweet yeah saw they do
but she said that he pushed her head
down towards his crotch correct which i
think is i mean if she's not I mean if
she pulled your it's not cool to do if
it's like a violent way if you're just
driving down the highway and she's like
okay gonna ride you grabbed her head and
it's like all right we can't yeah you
can't do that and do that you know if
you're driving fast you can put on the
brave yes you pull over
the Drule change a little but you can't
force someone to give you oral sex no
you just know that's frowned upon but
then the thing was a seventeen-year-old
that's the part that gets me the the
gets me more because this girl it seemed
like a lot of these a lot of ladies come
out to say stuff that's a little vague
ya know like I've been I'm not gonna lie
I've been making out with a girl before
and you know some one of us pulled my
penis out I don't know who it was you
know we're both in here it's tough to
tell could have been either one of us I
got just mouthing it up together who
knows you order this hard and stick a
case out but think of K so hot we're in
this mousetrap man alright okay so we do
mice one though is gonna hand John then
what I was trying to help the other one
eat it you don't have to say it like
who's the bad guy don't know I don't
know it's dark there's something you
know we both tried to get some mission
accomplished here yeah but but then the
thing was she said that he hit on a 70
year old friend I'm not doing it well I
guess he asked her friend to go to the
the hotel with them my issue is that
when he asked her that does he know for
a fact she's 17 I've seen some 17
year-olds where it's tough man yeah yeah
but if you look through at least two of
their pictures that's like he can
usually tell depends
yeah that's true it depends you know I'm
saying who knows but but then when he
hit up that girl on I guess he hit up
another girl on Instagram slitting her
diem she was three 17-year old yeah yeah
but I think he's like a notorious kind
of saw think he suffers from like sexual
addiction you know it doesn't [ __ ] all
the time yeah which i think is you know
and that and people have that it's a
real thing it's a real thing I think so
I mean I think it has something to do it
then feeling probably some insecurities
you know you'll think it's a cop-out no
because I want to [ __ ] but I want to do
it like twice a week you know not every
day [ __ ] no dude I'm not [ __ ] some
idiot every day don't see but here's the
problem you're talking that's the same
idiot what if you had seven different
beautiful no friends the hot the most I
would do is [ __ ] too hot too hot chicks
or seven and up a week or eight not
probably now eight no yeah cuz I'm older
am I doing that seven [ __ ] anymore
I'm an adult yeah makes sense yeah and I
mean seven as in I'm a scale of one to
ten I'm not talking somebody that's
seven I already told you guys about that
[ __ ] yeah you don't get down that like
telling nobody should know that we frown
upon that here at the find the kid Terry
Crews came out and said he had a
addiction of porn and said did he yeah
so he's jacking off non-stop oh my god
really
oh that queso stick damn boy cheese
hitting it up dude I can't imagine I
hear that oh my god I don't know because
if I were black got jerk-off out of time
though if you had that sweet dick that
sweet old the mic like yeah it's like
he's some black dude the sinner that was
in a fire I got a lumberjack accent he
got one or Bernard Bernard Bernard is it
a safe like name I think
yeah then it's kind of cool burn burned
if you like said yeah Burns is burning
yeah it's good options yeah like we had
a brother named
incidents in our town the accident
through story best brother name I've
ever heard
coincidence never seen the mom that name
there her two kids Lavoie Sheila dryer
it's real but one of my favorites was oh
uh this lady in my town named her kid no
Dante she goes because I knew he was
gonna be bad I was just gonna call him
Dante but I knew he was gonna be bad so
I called him no Dante
so when I say his name he already know
you're not supposed to be doing it no
great brilliant really no Danny I would
name all my kids that know Susie back to
take cruise in the sexual addiction is a
sexual addiction or is it the reason to
addictions because they have so many
options cuz they're celebrities you know
I'm saying well thank you I think it's
easy to judge but I think when you have
that many options I don't know if it's
an addiction take a question I don't
know what do you might be a lack of
discipline I don't think is addiction
you don't know maybe some small
percentage of people have an addiction
but I don't think it's for the mass for
most people I think could be addiction
because the release is like a certain
like dopamine dopamine yeah so you crave
that and so you you think of you know
sex you see the body and you you
constantly want that the dopamine so you
might correlate it it's kind of like
coffee even if you like or quitting
coffee you still like the smell of it
because it feel like you're like almost
drinking it again like with any
addiction oh I tried to quit coffee yeah
yeah or even quitting cigarettes dude
I'll [ __ ] you still smoke
oh yeah still smoke sometimes no I'm not
I'm doing good but I'm not doing great
you know probably smoke two cigarettes a
day I've been off coffee for have you
really like some force to cuz I was
thrown up I drink I drink so much coffee
my body Kym acidic and I would keep
throwing up
damn boy that's the dark Archer you
going that deep when your body turns
that said it yeah next thing you know
you end up being a [ __ ] one in one of
those Marvel comic it was so bad though
mad I just throw up non-stop like I
haven't been right
I know yeah man I worry about that kind
of stuff
I wish sexual addiction was for me you
know a little bit but then with drugs
and alcohol you can just buy it and do
it sex addiction you gotta be driving
around [ __ ] brilliant more semen in
your body well there's there's tinder
though right or there you could hire a
professional just come to your crib
yeah but the money oh that's true huh
yeah horse mates yeah dick mate Pro
Sunday brings his dick over well I
already got my own dead friends what
you're into wrong yeah not another's
trying to please that dick you know like
dick mate
would you dude that had a beautiful
butthole right but smallest dick he
could barely even see transsexual yeah
nice hair too dude so most transsexuals
that get you nice hair and wings
tattooed on his back
ooh learned a stripper like whoever you
want I'm a tough one
probably past okay you I don't think I
would man you know cuz I'm still trying
to get to heaven what would you get into
chin Shaun was a chump chin right yeah
thank you thank you sorry about that
what I get into I didn't think it was
Chun what do you would get into it what
are you in is sexual because you guys
get into the dark arts you guys are into
some wild stuff over there by the worst
example cuz you're pretty passive pretty
yeah I don't it'd be hard to get chin to
go on a date over spaghetti little trans
with a finesse I just not craving a date
yeah if I trans and some chicken wings
ain't his thing man really a flea no is
so super vanilla every time about
murdering hiding bodies and splitting
some cheesecake man what's a wild night
II like making a puzzle somewhere in a
van like what I'm trying to get a vibe
though you know good luck cuz he's been
trying to we have no idea what he does
now yeah just leather jacket on [ __ ]
Dexter I don't know what the [ __ ]
happening yeah you're like a UH you're
like a [ __ ] math bouncer you need to
go around with those [ __ ] Roman
numeral
I'm joking man that's pretty serious huh
no we have no idea what chin does on the
weekends yeah
June what would be a perfect date for
you we got this our show spots by
eHarmony for God's sake dude that would
be great to have your listeners to
describe like in 30 seconds what they
think chins weekend is like it'd be so
[ __ ] funny hilarious really vague man
you're kind of like that Mona Lisa oh
when you we like that
we'll ask him to show Big Jim with you
this weekend I'm like stop all right
cool man would you do some friends all
right what'd you guys do
went to cheesecake all right well it's
like that's wild man
did though I'm trying to think oh I grew
up with this boy who had this boy uh we
had this deaf kid in our town I'll tell
you this because I lived in there pretty
much in the Deaf Belt did growing up the
Deaf note they had a lot of death by us
because they had a couple of hearing
impaired schools by us and and so you
get a lot of extra deaf in the area you
know and it's why when you have a lot of
deaf people around cuz you don't know if
somebody's [ __ ] up or if they're deaf
mm-hmm you know so you're driving by or
if they're being rude you know so you
have to be careful I remember one time
this they had a deaf kid that moved in
right two doors down from us handsome
kid to think he could have been Italian
could have been kind of Creole yeah but
some kids beat him up they thought he's
doing bad magic you know cause he's
doing all this stuff with his hands but
yeah cuz he wasn't having me out yeah he
was doing all of this you know you gotta
be careful that bad magic [ __ ] yeah cuz
he kept doing all those hand signals you
know but no quarters no doves they
thought he was doing bad magic and they
[ __ ] beat his ass so that's the kind
of stuff that I don't like in the world
man when people are you know just not
trying to be a little more patient with
each other know the world's [ __ ] up
right now man we in it's like we're
calling people out for [ __ ] that
everybody else is doing you know it's
like Hollywood for you know all
throughout the the elections and
everything and I'm not a big fan of
politic of politics you know we had dead
animals in our ditch for like seven
years we complained about to the city
and they never came in
yeah plain awesomes and stuff oh no big
like an awesome no this is bigger like
what I don't know her medulla something
big man a couple times it was something
big dude and it shouldn't been out there
and somebody was throwing him out there
for seven years they'd like literally at
one point we just had a big stack of
bones that in one end of our dead damn
it could have been somebody who's
working in the vets or somebody working
with the hospital throwing stuff out man
did do you even wait right it isn't and
we would call the city and tell them to
come get it they never came and get it
so then you got kids out there throwing
[ __ ] bones at each other and just
stuff that's kind of [ __ ] up
and uh and so I never liked politicians
you know because I never liked that
because you if you were paid yeah yeah
if you were poor you didn't get anything
never didn't give a [ __ ] dude no there's
dead antlers kids there's [ __ ] two
kids playing hide-and-go-seek and a
[ __ ] carcass out here you know and
y'all don't give a [ __ ] no so but it's
just crazy to me like Hollywood will be
like you know all these politicians are
creeps and pedophiles and then it turns
out Hollywood's all creeps and
pedophiles so it's like you know this
shit's going on like if we can just all
try to get a little bit more realistic
and honest about what we're doing and
accept people have flaws yeah what the
[ __ ] do you know what you think people
are perfect now you know who's perfect
who is it Oprah mmm I don't know dude
we're stabbing at the next door shutting
the [ __ ] up was he there oh yeah he's
there he's stem and a lot of men don't
like that that docile man kept in the
distance afraid to say stuff probably
knows his role ya knows his word limit
was up years ago this hundred forty four
characters ran out a while ago do you
think politician it's all just gonna be
Hollywood is gonna be politics now it's
just gonna because Hollywood to me is
more powerful than politic then then
then they can persuade though yeah yeah
for sure well I think Hollywood's just a
small sample size but what what's going
on around the nation you know I'm saying
yeah like with the sexual assault that
happens in whether you work at Kinkos
where you work at Starbucks oh yeah yeah
it's not just not Hollywood and then
Seth Meyers yeah it's fun in some places
a little bit a little bit of sexual
assault depends if it's not nobody's
getting hurt and it's just kind of fancy
yeah all right it's not crazy if it's
not really assault
maybe sexual need like a different work
yeah maybe man
yeah but Seth Meyers had a good point
like we see it where these high-end
directors are doing it or these big
heads of executives of networks are
doing it but yeah remember on set
there's makeup artists there's freaking
you know the grip guys the cameramen the
the boom mic guy like there's a whole
staff they all deal with it too like
it's not just these big time people it's
an ecosystem and those people you've
seen that's just a sample small sample
yeah they crucified for it rightfully so
but I mean some but how do you even like
anybody any more than out here you have
to drive to Riverside to [ __ ] I won't
even jerk-off locally that's worth
getting for me I'm going to the valley
to bust nut oh dude yeah I'm not jerking
off in this [ __ ] in this count I
don't you the rest of you the [ __ ] how
come a little lands on somebody I don't
know screwed I think it's it's a phase
that things do need to change what's a
phase right now the target here's are on
you know white males but it's a face
yeah white males get pigeon over too
much they like to me anyway you know
it's like like we did everything you
know like we'd like what I didn't do
anything bad I don't think you know I
think if there's been in the minority
well the Russell Simmons yeah Simmons my
guy who's a head of like corporation
they got busted they say he was just
busting nuts on everybody yeah oh yeah
right start a downward dog and then just
put his dick in there really Wow let's
do it aggressive [ __ ] my thing is I'm
trying to stay out that internet I'm
trying to snap that pornography you are
you oh man why cuz it's influencing you
love live Island it can be if you're
googling the wrong [ __ ] yeah I'm just
sort of googling them you know what
bothers me is when I when I when I go to
porn this is videos you might like I'm
like I would not like that why do some
weed dudes in this thing what why does
that chick have a dick I did not ask for
this yeah like what algorithm does
youporn have it's like you might
this and it's some old granny get [ __ ]
like in what world I like this man how's
that happen it'll [ __ ] up your boner
deal oh yeah my boners [ __ ] from the
inner [ __ ] the whole vibe up I'm gonna
peel the outside myself you know
downtime yourself in the dark videos you
might like I could use something new
boom granny I did not ask for this or
its chick with a dick
definitely didn't ask for that I like
the old Greek ones they have like
there's old kind of Olympic style ones
where somebody throws a jab love it as a
dick on the front and like some lady
will catch it in her [ __ ] if I'm like
oh I've seen those 60 yards I've not
seen that one yeah it's very [ __ ] Dez
Bryant of her you know it's pretty crazy
I think your watch wouldn't feel bad for
him
I did I'll tell you exactly this just
happened to me man so I battle against
trying to jerk off cuz I'm tired of it
you know I'm saying getting old it's
getting old in that it gets old it's all
and it always going to the gym but every
goddamn day you're told
yeah yeah I used to go to the gym I quit
this year dude and it's one of the
neatest things I've ever done in my life
feel good about it I should be an addict
dude hide and [ __ ] just putting a
little bit of [ __ ] protein powder up
my ass it does on the suppositories I
was on all day trying it today
oh I'd sprinkle protein in a [ __ ]
bandanna tied around for heaven all
sweaty that's that rock you're gonna get
it in the [ __ ] straight to the brain
oh damn son hope you brought it I
stuffed my [ __ ] nose with amino acids
and go to sleep you know I'm saying dude
weird man
so what happened with your pointer or
you don't want to jack off anymore yeah
I don't want to John I want to do it
because here's what I started to notice
for myself was it got to the point where
when I can't when I would get off I
didn't even feel joy of this of watch of
thus I didn't feel a sexual joy I felt
like I just filled like I was just doing
something that was a habit yeah that
make any sense almost like brushing your
teeth yes it was like oh I just I'm just
doing it gets bored I'm just doing it
because oh I just did that habit I'll do
the same thing with Doritos
like why am i eating these I'm just
doing
I'm saying or no I'll boy yeah I'll eat
a bag of Doritos but either way when I
get we both get done like why I'm just
bored I don't need to bust nuts right
now
I don't this nacho cheese tortilla in my
mouth you know I'm staying through this
or somebody makes a poster of us and I
have like semen dripping off my hands
and your G us yeah but sometimes else
eat and drink is on board and then I'll
watch that's my hunt my 600-pound life
you guys have seen that [ __ ] mm you
don't watch a lot of TV be have you seen
my stick around life no I haven't seen
you guys seen it
it's pretty self-explanatory but people
are over 600 pounds and it's their life
and they gotta get their [ __ ] together
and some people on there like 900 pounds
eight huh they're [ __ ] huge that's
crazy but then they'll show their order
and you would think I see them they're
gonna die any second yeah I get hungry
from it really yeah I want what they're
having
damn yeah they get pizzas then they dip
it in the icing they get Cheetos they
down code Wow and I watch I'm like I'm
hungry as a [ __ ] right now it's
eight o'clock I had dinner Wow
but I'm gonna eat and are you able to
fight off their merges and late-night
urges and desires if I have something
coming up yeah like I'm busy now like
you have to be on TV after new comedy
I'll beat it but I don't have [ __ ] going
on
I'll post mates that [ __ ] damn you do a
lot of post mates huh yeah Wow yeah and
I feel like they judge me like the other
day you got three tubs of ice cream and
I was sick there my house and he goes
here's your three gallons of ice cream
man yeah I was like you know what [ __ ]
you bro [ __ ] you how about just give me
the bag who cares when I was uh when I
was growing up they had this dude you
could go watch him not really jerk off
but you could watch him kind of feel
himself in this video store and he was a
older gentleman he was older to us we
were children everybody was but he was
um they had like these wild Western
doors at this place called Pat's video
and they sold shrimp too right
so the place is trying to have videos
yeah a dream oh I agree
you get [ __ ] bloodsport it's exactly
we got it right you would only a couple
movies out then it was all Jean Claude
Van Damme
do they have sideboard um I don't know
what they had side oh wait I don't know
what that was all right that's a little
bit before Double Impact yep they're a
Double Impact got an American Ninja
Warrior
I mean they only had like six movies
then outside of that - shrimp but then
in the back they had these two wild
Western doors and 21 and up oh yeah
and we'd sneak over there sometimes and
they always have this dude in there mr.
earnest who lived in our town right and
he later on we learned that he was a
mentally handicapped but he was yeah I
mean I don't think he wasn't my dick
handicapped he was just mentally yeah
but one to bust nuts and work at the
video store
yeah he wasn't working there though he
was are you just hung out back there he
was working for himself oh this got
weird yeah oh so you just hang out in
that 21 and up video yeah he was legally
he could be in there so to him it was
like I was young I can be in it was just
Starbucks yes it stopped but he had a
bike a bicycle that had a baby seat on
the back you know cuz um somebody giving
him a woman's bicycle and back in the
day now you pull your kid in this little
carriage and all this [ __ ] he's in a
[ __ ] safety cage with these roll bars
hell yeah when I was young he was
buckled in with one [ __ ] buckle maybe
an elastic see but you know [ __ ]
sides yeah no helmet this before helmets
dude or if you got hit by something your
dad was in a [ __ ] wheelchair forever
well no back in this [ __ ] when [ __ ]
was legitimate you know dude course he
has dads with a [ __ ] bike helmet on I
would much rather have a dad that's
mentally handicapped from an accident
locally then dad who [ __ ] and then
ever see my father in a [ __ ] bike
helmet like he'll tell your dad that
come get it dad oh there's nothing my
dad put pegs on on his bike give me my
bro it's there that's way dangerous it
pegs on Helios dangerous dude this girl
Chrissy hunt my neighborhood lost her
second toe to those [ __ ] uh standing
on that barefoot that was her issue and
in that second toe and I'm gonna how you
get the second to do something the other
ones aren't doing but it was longer yeah
oh that's what it is the same totally
it's kinda like your middle finger it's
always longer than the other one
yeah so that second toad looking the
Raptor claw I can see how she got
cutting that spoke there is that what
happened it is and it ripped it off rift
it off dude it was out and about it
pulled it enough anywhere I guess they
couldn't fix it you know this is just
that well that's a bad one to lose you
all lose anyone lose your pinkie yeah
yeah I guess so you can lose on your toe
it's not that big of deal helps with
balance I one time was playing kickball
I I was snowboarding I think I was in
ninth grade ninth or 10th grade
now snowboarding my friend dare me to
jump off the left like snowboard like we
were [ __ ] XXX
I was like yea while I was up in the air
oh wow there's no doubt I'll I'll hit
that ramp and then [ __ ] zoom off he's
like do it well yeah Vin Diesel Stan
well it doesn't work like that in real
life I go off and I just play it into
the goddamn ice and then did just like
board up face-first broke my collarbone
so now I'm going down the lift in a
[ __ ] thing like this hold me down and
then I get to school that later that
week I'm in a sling cover playing
kickball with mr. with mr. bubbles
bubbles mr. bubbles great guy always in
sweats always had a fat dick on any
lights oh yeah so we're putting the rest
of the room playing kickball and I can't
throw it's my it's my it's my right hand
so I left hand I kind of sucked
oh I'm just back there dodging like a
[ __ ]
so it's everyone's outset for me and
there's balls there and then there's
like three kids left and the balls keep
coming me now all the balls are my side
band throw away I can't throw so then
the gym teacher go like the French do
okay just kick it Brendon I'm like
that's a brilliant [ __ ] idea
I go to kick it and I'm like I'm gonna
kick the [ __ ] out this ball and my big
toe we're barefoot cuz in the restroom
my big I kick as hard as I [ __ ] camel
he's kicking the game-winning field goal
and my big toe hits the mat first like
this and goes oh bro blew up on the
ground some kids still hit me with the
ball
[ __ ] you Travis that was his name Travis
it's always Travis anyways broke my big
toe go the
there's not much they can do for it Wow
you just got where's some [ __ ] Tevas
put a splint on it and there's nothing
in do they put brackets around it that's
a bummer
yeah more of the story if you're gonna
lose one you want the pinkie toe that I
ain't doing out that's how you get
started on it cuz you could still MA you
could still meander pretty well on it I
wasn't great I was out for a little bit
shoulder foot bad luck you know I don't
think anything ever wild happened to me
man uh you ready bad a dude in our
neighborhood they didn't have any arms
and always tried to [ __ ] with fight
people by head-butting huh you'd head
but he kicked hold up let me guess you'd
kick like an ostrich mmm oh he could
[ __ ] kick crazy dude fingers yeah he
had up and then this other kid in our
town a deaf kid this [ __ ] deaf kid
with a [ __ ] overbite bruh and that
dude would just he'd [ __ ] suck the
blood I did neck if he got close enough
to yeah yeah beautiful though but this
dude Clint was his name like Clint but
with an in in it as did at no arms dude
and he but he could [ __ ] literally
get you on the ground and choke you out
with his [ __ ] shoulder he was just
applying that pressure crazy bro I mean
he would just be on two legs but that
shoulder pointed right at your [ __ ]
esophagus did you do you ever have any
kids with was violent or mentally
handing out of driver's license that was
a crazy party remember that we drive
with his eyes I don't know what the [ __ ]
he was doing but he had a legal driver's
license how the [ __ ] did that happen no
arms one driver's license killing it not
fair
probably we can rubra no I doubt it
division tips
he's probably in prison dude I remember
he uh he did some bad stuff yeah you
remember this is about okay I was gonna
say you ever had any and I'm not making
fun at all anything like this we had a
kid in Down syndrome in my neighborhood
yeah dude and when I was like 12 he was
like 12 he was so strong yeah he was so
so strong and anytime even in middle
school I'm in school I felt like they
were stronger than the normal kids I
don't know if that's a generalization
but oh yeah they were really really
strong yeah I feel like they mature
obviously mentally they're not as much
ever I feel like physically the people
with Down syndrome and I'm
I'm just off but they were stronger than
the rest no because they get all their
who catch that ball and had dad strength
yeah I'm saying oh definitely dude they
could coach the team dude if they could
get the words out you know at the age of
six you know because they get all their
genetics at once so they get the whole
onslaught of genetics at once and their
body's just trying to hold in all this
madness
yeah I know I felt like you they're like
Wolverine and we're just peasants yeah
we had a boy on this can I grew up when
the maximum we could drink at the Ramada
in our town and he the Ramada Inn and uh
this was in Louisiana and Covington
Louisiana and I've even talked about
this so much oh this boy dairy was his
name dairy yeah it's me and he uh he
used to put people in that hard scarf he
called it the [ __ ] hard scarf dude he
had this [ __ ] head lock bro and you
had to have somebody help you get out of
it you almost had to get two black kids
help help you is that good
Oh bro when he put you in that [ __ ]
headlock that hard scarf boy yes it was
a hooker yeah even kill you if he if you
didn't get a couple of brothers come
over and help you out of it he'd [ __ ]
kill you you ever had a man choke you
out with his tits uh-uh
but I had that boy clinch choke me out a
couple times with this [ __ ] shoulder
and I guess I don't that's a rib or
whatever there's a high rib had a grown
man named Ron Waterman choked me out
with his titties man bring a picture of
Ron Waterman for me check out the titty
Ron Waterman on the his name you know a
fight name was mr. h2o autumn is that
thing was Waterman well mr. h2o oh wow
check out the tits handsome too he took
his tits almost broke my nose and he's
almost secular now no not at all
yeah and I didn't say that Ron he's a
tough fight he's [ __ ] rough fighting
well there's a couple pictures where
he's wearing jeans and a mustache and
then yeah I agree that's a little Shady
well those are gateway signs I'm a
sexuality where I'm from now I'll give
you that me too yeah we know you fought
him know he's won he's mine what was
especially my first start is one of my
main training partners and I was young
man and we started on the ground and he
took my and you know it's not even
jiu-jitsu it's just a [ __ ] homosexual
move yeah he took my head and had those
big packs those tan pecs they're all
greased up and sweaty and just went Iggy
oh my [ __ ] nose yes are they like go
out and I tapped I was so embarrassed
cuz my
friends were all laughing there is oh
definitely he was a monster ones
strongest guys I've ever felt
oh he looked like he never stopped
breastfeed nah you know he I did he
[ __ ] him with my nose it was so
embarrassing I thought maybe that's
important for me after that you know
dude I would just be so afraid if I
could never fight like you guys did man
I'll just be so afraid I would just
honestly defecate on myself or that I
would just immediately break my neck I
got a really lean esophagus to and I
would get choked out easy I'm just
scared of it dude
I wonder what Ron's doing do you get
more scared if you're fighting a black
hour or white guy do you feel like no I
don't care I don't discriminate I know
it's not not discrimination but just is
there any different so it's not a choice
you're making but it's like a different
fear that comes up no I think as I grew
up competing against but like my
neighbors the omnibox that's what I'm
used to
yeah it makes sense you know if you're
fighting a Russian or Croatian you have
your hands full
you're not gonna quit Russians are there
certain guys you can fight white and
black you know not Russians aren't white
but you know I'm saying like an American
white guy
yeah the American black every fighting
them maybe you might see a little
quitting and when the going gets rough
you fighting a Russian though or like an
African mm-hmm yeah they don't quit you
better bring your your lunch box
yeah Russian yeah I mean I can't even
those kids are [ __ ] over there
playing with stone dolls dude my buddy
told me that they had a doll oh yeah
children playing with stone dolls the
girls a doll made out a [ __ ] quikrete
or something like those kids are there's
no water there's it's [ __ ] crazy man
absolutely greatest fighter should we go
some current events Jen sure he's 52 all
right yeah what Ron Waterman Wow
well let me fight I know he retired a
while ago does say there yeah I'd love
I'm water that I'm gonna dot me Mark
Smith 2008 Rico Rodriguez lost to Dave
Herman lost to hogr Gracie
dam fought you lost a Mirko Cro Cop cro
cop soccer kicked them at the face or
those fights right there yeah they just
had oh no those are old
he beat Kevin Randleman how's my boy
what about um who's that guy [ __ ] uh
ready when you are breath trying to
think of his name there John Joyner is
that a fighter John Jones John Jones you
know I it sounds like you might we might
be seeing him sooner than we thought
that's what I'm talking so saying he you
might have accidentally took the stuff
he did so he might just get a year
suspension how do you accidentally take
note snorting cocaine and some [ __ ] was
laced in there okay what ok no drugs
yeah yeah I think the cocaine was laced
with some sort of [ __ ] some uppers
trauma bones and [ __ ] Deckard Dianabol
did I were one time we snuck back some
[ __ ] lynch jars something cuz they
only have three steroids you know what
like deca went strong with the other
test [ __ ] test you test 5000 do one
of my buddies his skull grew and that
was it joking people in our town named
gene you look like gene look like Bobby
big wheels
dude he came back to school the next
year he Reeves he had [ __ ] pie for
extra pounds of skull and sternum on him
and I was it and that's it nothing else
grew but we stole a bunch from Cancun
one time enough shampoo bottle brought
it back still dispersed it and everybody
used to do to win strong Oh bro you'd be
doing [ __ ] you'd be doin chest press
and [ __ ] two bubbles or just pop out
of your [ __ ] chest oh it was fun man
my buddy and I used to do it man it was
I just wanted to be jacked yeah this one
I was so skinny man I just felt so you
want to feel powerful I wanted to feel
some type of power in did it work yeah
made me feel good I'm er walking to
class one time is there any like
throwback Thursday pics of your anything
I like a probably fine time man fine
please send it to me yeah I will I'll
find something I'll put something up
good and reject oh dude I was [ __ ]
yeah
bro and I had the [ __ ] best body odor
to kind of [ __ ] that would bring [ __ ]
over you know really yeah nothing to
hardy but almost kind of like a [ __ ]
just like a homey kind of soup brewing
oh I won't like I'd like a Brad Pitt
from Fight Club vibe I felt like it was
a little more French coming out of me oh
I feel like something a little more like
a little more ethnic kind of like the
potpourri but you would see at a black
person's house gonna surprise you yeah
it's got some maybe some rose petals in
there but it's also might have some some
stake homes you know a couple of [ __ ]
cuts of steak comes in there and I hate
steak comes to as well even though they
sent me a t-shirt would you so were you
like tan and swole yeah man I wasn't too
tan I wasn't like you know you see those
guys on the New Jersey tan I was just
what was i you shot you had like a nice
base yeah it's pretty but I that's I was
in Louisiana could go lay out you know
you'd lay out on the car you park your
car inside an interstate and lay out we
do you have abs here I shred it up no
wasn't that shredded dude I never really
shred it well you know my body hides a
lot of [ __ ] um just extras in it and
so I'd be just kind of thick and awkward
I think you want a neck a lot of neck
code and it was very clear you're on
steroids I'm sure oh no I was so skinny
when I was a kid I don't even know if it
was some people could have thought I hit
a growth spurt you know really yeah but
then I don't know your some of your
friends never tell you because if I say
you don't know either with that that's a
good point and this was you know 15
years ago 20 years ago but if I see
dudes now that have all those little
pimples I'm like oh this dude a hundred
percent as a 30 year old you shouldn't
have pimples all over your back in the
chest yeah and it was addictive man like
look on a rock I don't really regret it
but I regret that I didn't probably stop
it a little bit sooner because that was
the problem I got addicted to just
feeling good about it was I felt good
about myself yeah you know high
self-esteem well yeah so when you got
off how did you deal with it well now
you don't work out at all yeah now I do
yoga now
so this yard is done yoga but next year
maybe or this year in a couple of months
mix again
yeah little winstrol little yoga ooh boy
I said I'm talking about two worlds Oh
bro that'd be [ __ ] great you know MJ
teaches yoga yeah she told me to come to
a class on Valencia BC Texas yeah yeah
what come on stretch in Valencia man
austra I'll stretch anywhere along the 4
or 5 or the 5 you had some current
events chips sure do
the first one's own life though does he
see the Dexter man dude that's the
yellow vault first one is a skit on
Jimmy Kimmel about Oprah but I don't
want to give it away so I'll just play
it for you guys real quick hands be able
to see this yeah let's see some of it in
Los Angeles last night for the 75th
annual Golden Globes and on hand to
receive this hustle B deMille Award was
none other than Oprah Winfrey who
delivered up I gotta watch her speech go
watch it it's too long oh this is nice
yeah but asking Oprah will run for
president
the E Network last night was fortunate
enough to have celebrity stylist Jason
Bolden with the shot to put Oprah's
remarks into historical context
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight wow that was almost like Oprah's
I have a dream speech
I mean I give how powerful Oh the King
bites all day my socks dude thanks
brother little jimmy kimmel parents not
mad at that Wow bro that's awesome huh
they're making fun of that guys for it
to make fun of Jason for saying you know
compared to Martin Luther King the dream
speech yeah I mean I yeah maybe so but
who knows how many people it inspires I
don't even know what fired on anymore no
me neither
Oprah's super powerful though yeah
Saturday now I said it again yeah I just
scary out there man but yeah if she
inspires women man and that's good you
know at least he didn't roast me or
nothing that's true huh were you nervous
a little bit yet have you nervous
sitting there huh
cuz you've never done that before I
never know how I was it uh before I was
due the this breathing that I did in
fighting to help me just wake up and
calm my nerves I it was doing the
breathing
I eat everyone's looking like what the
[ __ ] is he doing I just I like to just
be stag night to get up do my breast I
do it before every comedy show yeah and
then I hit the stage so I was doing the
same thing I think they're like addy
super nervous like now I'm showing you
the right frame of mind before I do this
[ __ ] Wow and then it was all good man
it was all good it's just a conversation
I never get too nervous about this stuff
like I didn't get nervous about when I
was doing the Mayweather and McGregor
stuff yeah she's bigger than the
different different bigger but I didn't
get nervous for that stuff just because
it's conversation right yeah and you
just stay in the conversation you don't
try to get too out here what's going on
no yeah yeah that's where the reps from
podcasting helps yes no one like listen
when you know go back and forth you're
not really gonna allow dead air yeah
that probably had you know the they
might do more TV spots like this than me
but I've had my 10,000 hours podcasting
right talking to some pretty smart
intellectual peeps like yourself you
know yeah dude I was uh 3.2 baby okay
Oh as if 3.20 grade point average GPA in
high school yeah great I didn't give you
in anywhere these days kids have to have
4.0 extracurricular activities invent
apps
[ __ ] just again to any college around
here it's so competitive yeah if you're
white you know mm-hmm
if you're white wall but you better dye
your skin you know what I'm saying but
you better claim that 2% Native American
do find it you know I'm saying dig up
somebody in your backyard and bring
their bone 21 in me and lie about it
African and you something do find a
Kemosabe to jerk off into that
ancestry.com kid Harbor sense in that
[ __ ] boy my son he's [ __ ] without you
I am the Mexican oh you Mexican huh
there's miles back tunes [ __ ] dude get
some pictures him outside dude he's a
nice space already you get them outside
use that red skin we're going any
Stanford here we come
will you get to pictures him outside
with nothing back behind it makes people
think I call where's this kid from yep
and then you write that in with the
application with the essay yeah talk
about hard work in the fields yeah well
they know he's Rich's [ __ ] grew up in
[ __ ] the Palisades yeah boy wow it
sounds like a nice kid you don't to be
adopted it I'll come of it I'll adopt
you what do you got what else got you um
I won't be at the Brea improv this
weekend oh my bad go ahead you know
we're still gonna improv I love playing
one of my favorite spots me I'm excited
about there all weekend yeah Thursday
through Sunday and then I'm in
Jacksonville next weekend you Jackson
haven't been out that I'm doing Florida
end of March yeah it was good though I
love Florida dude you know a lot of
missing people over there and I love the
missing and um but they have but
Jacksonville is pretty wild it's a lot
of driving around and getting nowhere no
matter where you are yeah I spent some
time in Jacksonville my boys from there
and I would do his charity all the time
up there and Jackson was kind of like
it's the slower region of Florida oh
yeah a lot of bodies in Jacksonville
they haven't found I know that yeah
that's true and I said look for bodies
and always young along interstate
there's a little bit of the older folk
there but not as old if you go down like
a Boca Raton area yeah where there's
anti-aging clinics literally like
Starbucks here everywhere yeah you can
get a [ __ ] you can get a latte in a
damn reconfiguration right there at the
counter are you a latte nose dropping
all day they'll give you square eyes
down there a lot of what you call
[ __ ] for money down there if you got
hard dick and some [ __ ] time to kill
you can go down there and get into
hunting wheels down there you can get
into some wheels because a lot of ladies
with money looking to catch that last
[ __ ] seven inches for they go to
heaven or hell
and you can get down there and find some
women with money that will leave you
money in there will ya because then they
have extra cash flow because it's the
Florida taxes yeah they don't you don't
have any state tap it's a great point so
they're looking to spend that cash on
young men yeah that's a good point you
like it easy entry I'm a little old for
that
really yeah how do you think Janice do
it have told you this before then we
talked about this but I would go
probably 28 to 48 you want that's a fair
range he's 40 is it really yeah I could
see that matter cuz he'd be in 40 or
even 45 thanks I'm here a little bit but
you're here Jim
no I used to oh really what color black
just to make your hair as black as your
coat son I'm sure I dyed it like maybe
like a five six months ago yeah Abby's
grown if you have craze if not upgrade
yeah I've some great so you have Gray's
yes my chin it's freaky nothing wrong
little salt and pepper
now you go full Jay Leno although that's
kind of in you look like the [ __ ]
Dragon Queen though I just look it's all
sparse and out of nowhere so it's weird
do you this give me a crazy question I'm
not trying to be offensive but it's good
out do you feel agent or not are you
like a regular person
that's a fair question but you don't say
I see what you're saying that like do
you feel like a minority and the like we
definitely feel if I'm around like like
just us here I definitely do feel like
I'm Asian
wow so that's actually a good question
you mean just oh what do you mean in
studio you'll feel more Asian around me
and Brian then you like a much cuz I'm
all my friends are pretty much Asian so
when I'm around like just all white
people is the conversation different way
around just them I think just cuz
they're my friends it's different but is
it different could you guys talk about
more stuff that the Asian culture be
into I would say this we are definitely
different there's different things like
little things that we do differently
like what I don't want to bring about
why not because I mean I feel a little
bit better after hearing you say that I
feel a little like yeah and I feel like
like we're gonna catch a wall
no just brings for my attention that
maybe sometimes you know that you know
that my point of view could be kind of
narrow sometimes but no the joking stuff
I love I think most people enjoy that
it's just humor but I'm saying like just
different things that we do like maybe
the way we eat or the way we use the
bathroom and stuff like that if those
things might be a little bit different
oh yeah like do you guys slurp your
noodles and share right that's yeah
that's one thing like that we were next
to a family over in Central City Mall
and they have a ramen place there and
Emma I don't kind of I don't know if
it's Japanese Korean restaurant but you
we gotta go there Qin you should see
this place it looks ridiculous sweet and
oh it's just packed with people from
Asia so that's how you know it's good
like there's no white person in there
anyways so we're eating over there and
I'm having myself a nice Mediterranean
meal and the family next to us is they
look Japanese I have these noodles and
they're slurping on ya and teaching
their son to slurp them it's the way to
eat the noodles its way through Dover
here you know there's different things
that are rude that uh that you guys
might do that we look at as rude I can't
really think of it right into the way we
talk to women as we do we see more room
that kind of stuff maybe just like when
you come in here and then if someone
comes in here and they don't like offer
a seat or something like that like
something I could just see someone
bypassing without thinking twice like
hold a good door for a lady that's here
holding doors well you know you're just
talking I see that's that culture thing
just around digs yeah that could be true
[ __ ] I wish I could hold doors for
girls I still open my car door for my
girl you know I still do that [ __ ] do
you do you feel like that because I bet
we probably seem real more like
ego-driven yes that's actually super
super smart man that's exact one time so
driven meaning like the people you meet
in here cuz you meet people in show
business though no that's a good point
but white people were more like
egotistical in a weird way it's a noble
nopperz not like a dick way it's just
it's just a little bit more ego I notice
yeah a little bit more you I bet you and
your friend do you bet you and your
friends don't fart around each other no
you know yeah and I don't and I don't do
that either around other guys
thank ya I don't either I'm kidding dude
with Cuba sakes if you're close friends
you fart but I'm not gonna just random
dude and fart in front of them yeah I
just probably guys wouldn't do it at all
that'd be savage dude there's a tap of
random personal shoulder and tell him
you're farting probably gotta make this
video it's a good idea it's just called
apologize first and you apologize me you
don't tell them why do you guys look at
girls on Instagram what do you mean like
do you know like sometimes I'll be like
I'll be at the Comedy Store and you know
so I'm like dude let me this like check
this girl out or something like that do
you guys do that or yeah it's it's hard
to pinpoint what it is but I think feels
right on point when he says it's just
it's a certain amount of ego like we're
just way more I would be way more
welcoming or respect yeah but it's not
like you guys are doing it to be dicks
it's just we were raised just this way
but what's weird the Koreans yes but
then like when we're in the airport and
I deal with this here and I have nothing
against them sometimes just happens but
like with the Chinese I feel like
they're rude to me you know what they
are like when people are speaking super
loud in front of funny behind me
whatever it's still rude it's still but
I'm also super Americanized too he did
grow up in Texas yeah did you really
yeah if you guys but he would but you
were you born in Korea born in Korea but
I went my live in Texas oh I think Texas
is it's gonna be whenever if there's a
big war that comes in the future between
like a met between like Los Angeles in
New York and the rest of America if
there's ever if things ever get that
divided the capitals will be in Chicago
in Texas I think of like the other mid
the rest of us safer in Texas so Texas
doesn't [ __ ] around normally [ __ ] de
Texas Texas you know won't be a no pass
on the on the board of war s because
they have their issues but I feel like
if you're in Austin
you're pretty chill you know I've run as
guns so no one's gonna pop off right and
they have a lot of diversity in Texas so
I think they're you people in Texas are
used to being around other cultures and
other ethnicities hundred percent in a
weird way a lot of people think like oh
Texas but I think there's some of that
old boy ISM some of that [ __ ] or some of
that but for the most part it's a
melting
it's a [ __ ] melting pot and it's just
about you work hard you [ __ ] get your
life [ __ ] a football [ __ ] out you
barbecue ya drive trucks ya drive trata
blonde white girl yeah but some of these
blow my car me that [ __ ] so ever
you know her blonde white girls I think
like a southern belle make this sum up
yeah look some of them I'm still around
but some without the only thing I'm like
quit talking like that and let's [ __ ]
figure out what the [ __ ] going on
yeah that's you talking about where they
talk when they're in a pageant or some
[ __ ]
yeah some of that yeah I don't mean that
southern belle I just mean like a
southern belle who like you know I'm
saying the Rings it takes care you know
just holds the fort yeah that's true oh
I like a hard walk I see you during the
day when the baby's asleep constantly
watching [ __ ] reruns of Walker Texas
Ranger yeah yeah just polishing your
badge yeah yeah yeah and they get that
badge polish yeah and then I get home
and she gots the smoker on the breast
and [ __ ] and then she's making some nice
mac and cheese got that Georgia ass too
much there no it's good man look dude I
fell asleep one time on a plane I was on
pill on some type of Downers you know
air down her sleepers sleepers yeah what
is it
allotted or something fall/autumn I
don't know some kind of [ __ ] that put
you to rest you can sleep on a plane
value valium and I found myself I was in
a sex dream dude I found myself acting
out like I was doing oral sex you know
and uh I was on a plane man like you
like this drugs gay well look not me
but men by that Ripper but what I'm
saying is some do woke me up cuz I was
literally doing oral sex in my mind like
in the air you know wow you were [ __ ]
your [ __ ] jaw and I wasn't even I was
just naturally just flying you know just
on these you know flying damn pills
you're completely sober now though right
yeah yeah you still do all that like and
how is it a like a something you have to
deal with every day like you is there
like some sort of struggle we like you
know I'm saying oh my god I don't know
I've never been addicted like that like
cuz you you have to go and I don't know
if I can say this you tell me but you
have to go like meetings and stuff still
right yeah I go to meetings man I go to
meetings vodka but I go I find that I
never had a problem drinking you know I
like doing a little bit of cocaine here
and there sometimes I'll still watch
videos of people doing cocaine on the
Internet
I'd also watch funerals on the internet
so that kind of gets that high out of me
but what I'm saying is that I will I'll
I go for the fellowship and for the
camaraderie you know just it's just like
a group of friends oh dude it's all a
little [ __ ] up yeah and the stories
that they share is so real so it's like
I need something real and my I need
something to be [ __ ] real or my
attention do you have a good group of
friends out there besides those guys not
that much so you go to them for so I
think that's it for advise me like man
I'm tweaking man about the yeah but I'm
never tweaking like I'm just like hey
man I'm having a tough time with this
girl I'm having a tough time like
feeling like like I can handle this day
or I'm having a tough time like you know
going into this meeting and I'm question
what I should do or I got this auto
lease and I don't know to like it's
almost like you can get like you know
father figures and brother figures in
the car so that's the kind of stuff that
really keeps me and it's like emotional
sobriety and are most of them do they
have your background in the show
business or they just regular 9:00 to
5:00 I'll go to a mix of meetings I go
to some where there are people in there
where you know I've been in the meetings
in this past week with Academy Award
winners and and boxing national
champions yeah yeah boxing like
heavyweight champ yeah a lot of those
things I mean especially in LA it's like
almost a networking thing - it's like a
boys club of super successful people
that just happen to have yeah a
politician and then I'll go in and ones
also go to ones where it's like real
people like where it's like homeless
dudes sitting in there next to you just
because that's kind of the environment I
grew up in a little bit more like just
regular people feel comfortable and so I
feel yeah I feel like I need to see that
a lot so that I don't forget what the
world is like you can zone yourself off
and make your world however you want it
to be you know and I find those with
those celebrity people I don't mean
interrupt
not a celebrity people talking are there
other problems different than you know
I'm saying like you yes I come on man
like he's a guy like this week on social
media the hate has just been well
there's I mean there's groups for even
like people that are to get a chapstick
you know they can be bought there that's
rockin them [ __ ] that makes sense I
know a few people do to chubster yeah
people that are [ __ ] can't get out of
bed with you know dropping two tubes and
ninety SPF on their yeah yeah man
there's people like that for there are
and there really are group for that so
there's groups for everything but yes
some people's problems to me are not big
problems but to them and their limits
big and so then I have to recognize it
to them this [ __ ] this problem is
real to them and then it's important and
so then it tries to take me out of being
judgmental you know cuz my mind is it my
enemy is in my mind it might sound crazy
to some people and I don't think about
this [ __ ] all down and go to these
meetings every day you know I live my
life regular but there's something in my
mind that doesn't want me to be the best
person that I can be yeah and I know
that my heart wants me to but my mind
will try to trick me of sabotage will
try to self-sabotage me man it is my
mind is just as crafty as I am as a
person you know it's just as crafty and
it'll sneak in on me brother find ways
to trying to start saying stuff yeah say
stop me I flick stuff comes into you
yeah make me feel less then make me yeah
make me nervous frog on stage so it's
like you got the [ __ ] you know
diamond yeah you get that demon you got
the dark alright changing demon get that
Cajun demon boy hey you know but you
seem like you've wrangled him in I don't
know it was a battle and that's why I go
to the meetings because it's a battle
really and are they having the same
issues
some guys are there's always somebody
who has the same issue or something
similar so you can relate to yeah I got
friends that are flashers I got friends
that are last year's like they when cars
drive by the flow dick or boy but uh you
know it arrested these days for that I
don't know anyway that does but anybody
that but flashes is awesome well that's
what we used to do his kids like cars
drive by would just flash our buck and
run off like hey come last me you
thought it was so dangerous a naughty
okay kids get arrested these days I was
just are fun that's something that
Asians
that's disrespectful it's something I
don't know what it's hilarious this is
what it is and don't kill themselves if
they're not doing good you guys would
kill yourself a lot of a lot of people
do see we just talked about that
Japanese suicide forest yeah yeah yeah
but yeah that stuff that this it we
would laugh at it but we just wouldn't
do it would you guys don't flick each
other in the day no that's no they don't
agree that's insane that's insane
did if he did that his grandfather would
kill himself right that's absolutely a
lot more honor feel like you guys have
more of like a solid family structure is
that true hardcore yeah super Steve you
know what names the biggest Korean porn
star it's probably frowned well I mean
come on Asians important women yeah
women of course but not really man dudes
yeah but I could see some crazy [ __ ]
dudes like dudes jumping off a cliff so
I didn't like a woman's ass like they
take it over the top like oh you're
gonna do that cool oh you guys bust on
girl's face here's a [ __ ] video and
there's 70d yeah that's true there's go
way way deep I see guys like cartoons
you have any anime let's [ __ ] you guys
yeah well you like action movies check
this out we're gonna do a movie here
that's 30 years too late but still gonna
kill at the box office
grab John Claude Van Damme [ __ ]
Arnold Schwarzenegger Wesley Snipes and
they just kill in the box-office yeah oh
you guys like scary movies and you guys
always [ __ ] do it better like the
ring all are scary movies a lot of it
comes from Japanese and Korean is it
really yeah we just redo it here but I
think the scary movies back in the day
used to be about like a man in the woods
killing somebody and now it's more like
this good humans it's a little bit more
yeah demon you know why why the man the
woods ain't fun anymore Wow cuz it
really happens right the demon we can go
and still be entertained like I can't
get almost
I'm balls deep in the el chapo I'd
finally finished season to last night's
the life star and El Chapo but it's a
it's a TV series on Netflix it's
brilliant but I almost turned it off
because it's too real and this stuff
actually happens because they killed
this man's two kids they threw him off
the bridge and they showed the video of
the kid the actual video of the kids in
the car like sleeping they tricked them
this guy tricked them then they threw
him off
the this huge bridge and then murdered
their mom it's just to like I don't need
that in my life man
I just don't like the world's dark
enough I don't need to in my downtime
watch that [ __ ]
yeah that's dark man super dark so i
yeah i really don't i kind of zone up
from all that stuff but i saw like the
conjuring and insidious four and all
that and that i've way more fun going to
watch because it's not real
right like I'd rather watch that then
watch like a hostel which going to
people getting cut up and stuff because
that's real yeah yeah like that kind of
stuff can really be happen what are you
guys what do you like you know I hate to
say you guys I feel like I'm always
trying to get you to speak for like
everything east of Poland it's all make
sense though but yeah what we're saying
like wait what are you and what John or
a movie do you like yeah when it comes
to horror stuff what's it like for
people that are similar maybe to you or
not and that kind of look like a little
bit yeah ballpark
I do like creating the horror films the
the one but I do it when I agree I don't
like the gory stuff I like like mental
thrillers things that are just
suspenseful mentally yeah yeah and dark
and scary and ghostly
is that your favorite type of movie not
John Rowe so you know that I got a
little [ __ ] in fact they feel you know
he sings country music know any other
generalizations about I do a lot of
[ __ ] balls I started [ __ ] [ __ ]
mosh pit against each other dude I can't
believe that really and he can say Jim
why just play a video form for me get
work play a video chip so it's so we can
educate them did hockey get you some
work over [ __ ] sky probably this
afternoon you know and you know he also
did a voiceover for Rango if you know
that movie
Rango on that Johnny Depp movie
here's chin sing again
Oh
[Music]
Wow dude just [ __ ] shattered every
stereotype I ever fought o-line blown
that's what I want to bring you in
that's crazy right yeah dude that's fast
yes welcome that screen Garth Brooks
[Music]
Garth Brooks was remembered he did that
weird ones
Garth Brooks it's just like oh you need
to get over I can boo t-shirt and a
viking hat come out waves to an
invisible audience god Brooke you could
kill it show you in five days you did
that I'll share the [ __ ] you also
know chin used to be over 300 pounds no
way I was 285 oh I'm sorry I'm off my
bats in one at 85 you're expecting to be
that Chloe is a fighter you know I
should know but it used to be 285 pounds
Wow they also used to be in a boy band
that's why you're so kind I can tell
because people that are worth big and
lost weight are always very kind always
right for a percent you know what is
first in their very kind on the internet
they're very mean oh wow how does he can
get away with it because I can't see the
cheeto fingers hmm so they be the last
people that to comment on oh you're not
talking about weight stuff right I am
talking my weights you don't know when
they're big a lot of times and this is a
generalization we've done this others
show worlds in general I know but a lot
of times a lot of the hate come from
they hate themselves so when they see
you doing something they want to spew
that hate on it yeah that makes sense
it's like yeah there's something in me
when I see somebody and it's envy or
some it just turns into fear inside of
me or some and then jealousy and then
lash out you envy what I mean I other
comics I wouldn't be other comics for a
while sometimes these days I don't as
much because I
a little bit more Fokin yeah a little
bit more focus on what I'm doing then
before when I was a little bit just like
this you're trying to find your lanes
now you finally finally found your path
and office here is legit as it comes as
a comedian I think sometimes be confused
with jealousy with inspiration like I'll
see what Rogen's doing I'll see what
you're doing or Chris D'Elia or any of
the top guys bill burr geek Kevin Hart
for that matter he's taking the torch
and [ __ ] ran with it it's well it's
not there's no jealousy and zero it's
almost it's just inspiration yeah
yeah I think damn I want that for myself
like I'll see I go oh damn I want that
for myself that would be a home run for
me man yeah odd it's cool to see someone
doing that well yeah I mean you've been
sticking with this for a while now man
how long you been doing stand-up for
when I did my first live find the kid I
don't know four years ago three years
ago when I did my first set set like own
personal set probably I don't know two
years ago maybe and then I've been on
like doing my own like straight-up show
like our show oh yeah I started when was
the first big brown at I saw I saw snow
last around December like December
January I think last December right and
you facility we started in January he
facilitates at all well you facilitate
all that when they go do it we know we
did the big brown breakdown alive for a
good chunk of it where we just do it
like we do the show but now he's
straight up stand up
but do you go and do the live show when
they go do it some of them some of them
some of them because that was the
evolution of kind of when I got into
stand-up is I would do the live podcast
but it was just a way for me to get
stage time with my craft oh yes yeah I'm
doing this but then I do you know 30
minutes stand-up before and then talk
about the fights and the Dufresne
questions yeah and then once I wrote
enough material it's like nope just all
stand up now yeah there's like these
training wheels I've been so fortunate
man so fortunate have a platform to do
it yeah it's cool man
it's been interesting me this whole
world is gonna gentleman when I started
doing my own podcast like a year ago
I was like I don't know anything to talk
about and then like it's just how we
build almost more self-confidence
yeah to be able to talk and listen to
guys like you know Gaza krogan a spaz
actually just in getting like
encouragement from guys like that you
know we're being able to ask you about a
question you know like what do I do here
you know I feel like Parkinson's
therapeutic a little bit because again I
ones a lot I mean you and I see each
other at the comic store and we'll talk
for a little bit maybe 20 minutes max
from the back but go on maybe thirty
minutes it but it's a group of us was
spitballing [ __ ] and try to make
each other laugh but here I mean we've
talked for damn to two hours now you
know I'm safe so it's like when is the
second longest conversation ever video
yeah broken being the first yeah but I
feel like it's there you know it's
almost therapy yeah it's nice yeah I
think so man I think it's definitely
interesting I appreciate you guys having
me and I can't believe Brian's this late
[Laughter]
I don't know if I could have I saw that
it was on variety so I can say it so
remember when Brian shot that spin-off
and he got canceled I cried for Brian
Wow it's a big moment for him and I
he'll he's gonna hate me for saying this
Brian has always been the guy cuz when
showbiz is so long his heart's so
ice-cold from it and he's so
non-emotional about acting comedy he
doesn't give a [ __ ] you know I got sold
out Wilbur he's like pretty cool anyways
you want a ham sandwich I'm like yeah
all right man but that's just Brian yeah
just so he's the kid he's the kid named
him that self but anyways so he this is
a year ago maybe are in May he shot a
spin-off for the Goldbergs where he's
the coach and here's a big role in it
and I was telling him like dude it's
gonna happen this is gonna happen for
you and I was encouraged him and he'd be
so negative and drove me [ __ ] nuts
and I might just admit you want this man
he's like no no I don't care I have no
controller I don't care this is show
business Mike alright man and then we'd
be just mean him I'm like dude admit you
want this for me like nope not gonna do
it
then he text me at midnight I've never
forget this he was in San Francisco he
was in San Francisco maybe he's in
Denver doing shows and he texted us hey
brother I find out tomorrow morning if I
get the show you're the only one I'm
going to tell this to but it's gonna
hurt if I don't get it wow I was like
you're [ __ ] kidding it man you're
getting it I get goose bumps on Matt and
then next morning cause his first call
happen oh yeah I do so I lied to him I
was so heartbroken for men I was so sad
for him cuz I knew how even though he
won't admit it how bad he wanted that
yeah Bryant's I would give a [ __ ] what
he tells you guys Brian's number one
passion is acting yeah Brian came to LA
to be an actor and sometimes though in
Brian's us very successful actors yeah
yeah it works non [ __ ] stop Brian's
on the gold Brooks Brian compares
himself to Hugh Jackman and fight you
know these Kevin Hart's yeah count him
so to him he's a you know this was his
big break well today I go on variety
like I do every morning like a goddamn
gentleman and I'm scrolling through and
it says the spin-off of the Goldbergs is
RiRi erected know what has erected
they're gonna bring it back and test it
but they're gonna the but they're not
testing it just a sample gonna put it on
they're gonna put it on this whole time
and didn't tell us this yeah why just
say just remember price shut up about
people have to listen all the way
through our [ __ ] Joe dude that is
chauvinism so he must be ecstatic nope
talk to him about it cuz I could send
that little bro it's I [ __ ] told you
maybe not maybe that happened the way
you wanted to but it's happening and he
goes that they're just gonna test it
doesn't mean they pick it up we got a
response [ __ ] you [ __ ] off I always
think the best I don't mind being broken
hearted man I don't know I listen I'm
waiting Maronites was say so with e
another thing I did for them for the
Golden Globes yeah that was my tryout to
be on e yeah so if that went well they'd
have to pick up my other options for
Kadim e Ward's Oscars Met Gala right so
if that went well I don't know yeah I'm
waiting to find out do I want that [ __ ]
yeah I love doing that stuff man
the Brian's like no just take it out of
your mind like but why I don't mind be
it I'm not embarrassed if I don't get it
you don't give if I tell the for you you
know I'm saying I don't care you're
gonna use a lot of face moisturizer
probably probably you have to get some
da tears bigger ears put on probably
right
eventually getting two years you can
have [ __ ] big ears you're gonna be so
different your neck file down a little
bit on the sides let's finish these Curt
events van McMahon I have one question
do you think he that he doesn't get the
excitement because like why because he's
what he's a he's a from whatever yeah
it's not it seems like he's just he's so
used to not getting it he doesn't want
to prepare himself to gets the nature of
the business
seasoned amazing actor right he's been
he's been this clean O'Brien was
supposed to be will unwilling grace came
down to Kim and the guy who got it oh
did you guys know that no that guy is
you know I don't either grace that was
supposed to be Brian you know I'm saying
so and he's Brian's been this close to
this movie and this close to this movie
and this and this is this so after a
while he's like it's out of my control
man I'm not gonna put entered and I get
it I'm different he goes you know I'm
sound my control and could put energy in
that cuz the chance of that happening
there's so many moving pieces I've
learned the hard way myself I had this
pilot I shot and it was took a year and
a half for them to finally turn it down
but they kept dangling from my face I
tell Brian it's happening it's happened
and he's like no it's not bro you think
you don't understand I'm not saying it's
not but it's so out of your control
saying funny you did your job you gotta
hate great job but there's so many
moving pieces and for a show to get
picked up it's not even funny and I'm
running this now with this venture I'm
doing I can't right now but I'm learning
it now yeah we're just like holy [ __ ]
there's so many to get this train moving
there's so many pieces yeah and that to
Brian's point and he's pretty the way he
does is probably the correct way to do
it I like to be excited as [ __ ] like
that be I like the ups and downs not not
saying when I when I don't get a job not
brokenhearted right I like but when I do
get it it's so much more right and maybe
it could because I mean and this is me
just throwing things out thought because
I totally understand where Brian's
coming from like I'm 30 years yeah and
he does it he just protecting himself
you know in this town will you can be
the best at something in not and it's
not even about that and never get your
shine yeah and it's not even about that
you know but
I honestly believe Brian's won the best
comics in the world uh excuse me what
she seem in person yeah Brian and what
we selling it tastes funny on this Mike
Wright and his specials are good but
Brian in person is the but one of the
best conversation in the world if the
video doesn't do it justice justice and
I don't know how they could get that to
come across but someone well
Brian's one big Netflix special from
just blowing up which if anyone deserves
it's him Brian give me fifty one wow
really
51 nothing needs a moisturizer you use
he does that's what I've been thinking
about when you I'm not around I know
he's he needs the hair transplant day
you went partying people to do it well
tell Brian and I'll pay for it oh I get
a discount
well I got one guy's legit he will not
just put hair on you for no reason no
one for it like don't get me wrong up
and we would always figure out how to do
the front kid but if Brian came he was
like bro I've blown up so much I get my
spin off on the on ABC and now I'm a
movie star fired kids stuff for me to do
now it would don't Iran I love doing so
Brian he's my best friend and break my
heart we'd figure something out to still
put it on miter in the kimchi move up in
over it and fighter in the steel spider
in the Thea did I get out of here fight
I'd be broken hard but I'd be also be so
happy for Brian yeah man I'm gonna think
about that I'm gonna wish that for him
because I you know sometimes you forget
you see these guys in passing a lot you
know at comedy clubs you forget some of
the struggle and Brian seems so young to
like he's just so [ __ ] vivacious and
young you don't you forget that
I mean I'm 37 so that's another 13 14
years of struggle he's had out here and
major struggle to you don't like Brian
he's so talented I remember seeing him
on yeah on TV showing me like Dan that
guy's hilarious you know II always do
anything act so that shows you it's not
about that it's about these other
[ __ ] mooks out here just depends
where you need your break maybe Brian
gets this break it fit you and that's
happened for some up and I'm not it
we're sounding like Brian hasn't been
successful Brian success one he's a work
in acting lesson actors but I'm talking
about Reena breakout star where Brian
you know he's doing his heels justified
correct he hasn't felt justified yet
yeah I can I can totally empathize with
that I want that for him
yeah I do too man I'm gonna think of
that that he that he gets that did imma
put that on my show my hopeless yeah
because he deserves it man will put my
stuff on the - there's only one from a
burner we just [ __ ] put the kid on it
I know but yeah put me uh sometimes
people have to do we don't have to your
you start off another burner that's
right
what's your bro the skillet all right
Jim what else you put you in the skillet
moving the skillet Doug all right
this is everywhere as you know it the
H&M ad that came out about a little
black kid wearing something on his
hoodie this is coolest monkey in the
jungle you guys you guys did hear about
this is that racist deal I don't think
so I think this was an accident and I
think at a certain point that we have to
stop saying that everything is racist
it's like it's almost becoming starting
to be for me the boy who cried wolf it's
like I don't think I don't look at this
and think that this is racist if someone
does look at it and they say oh this
this is race is you're racist yeah I
didn't have that thought in my mind what
my girls show me this I'm like okay
what's wrong with this hoodie she's like
it says monkey on I'm like but he's not
a monkey she's like well that's racist
I'm like if you think of black bears
monkeys it is right and back in the day
people referred on that but I don't come
from that culture I don't come from that
background so I see it I'm like that's a
cute little black boy you know the
coolest monkey in the jungle and then
some white kid with a shitty haircut
that says from the Allison Grove jungle
yeah yes
it's a jungle owner and [ __ ] like that
and you're like then you're like what
the [ __ ] going on here yeah if that
little white boy sweatshirt said monkey
owner and then his church says coolest
monkey then we got problems
yeah but if you're hmm you're such a big
thing like big corporation just to be
safe I don't put the bike in the monkeys
that's exactly the argument that's what
I don't think they're races right no
they're saying it's poor taste you
should have known better you have so
many people in the company letting this
passed by so it feels as if they wanted
that to get out
or they're just so anti-racist they
don't like what or that's it the awesome
are you kidding me right nobody's
thinking that anymore like we do it's
[ __ ] doin 18 yeah but some parts of
South Carolina are thinking that but
other than that no really and also some
parts of black culture kita need to also
I think in this I mean I'm not black but
need to quit if they sometimes it's just
like don't if you continue to just push
this that this everything is wrong
there's always gonna be that way I agree
if we just don't bat an eye to this and
just like that's a cute black boy in a
shirt that says coolest monkey in the
jungle yeah now is it racist if the
white kid was in a sweatshirt too that
says coolest monkey in the jungle if
they're both in the same thing is that
racist now that might have been a better
idea
yeah that'd be different that would be
the men that would be different but it
would still point they would look at
that little black kids but you know have
you thought of maybe you know a lot of
different companies make these kind of
risky headlines to get headlines correct
and then sometimes it overshoots then
this time it bit them in the ass like I
wonder if that might have such a big
bite in the ass though I know that's
what saying sometimes it works but then
this is horribly going wrong and all
these different celebrities like the
weekend he cut his deal with HM and so
did Jeezy they both had left well I mean
well they have pressure from fans to do
greed and H&M also also makes shitty
clothes now anyway it used to be a
little bit more quality I mean that's
the same company on my Zara Zara used to
be nice and now it's [ __ ] you're
going to Zara and it's like a violent
H&M in there yeah it's so messed up but
then celebrities just use stuff like
this to make them look a certain that's
also true too and then all them things
that I'm tired
so Jeezy says sorry guys over the past
months I was genuinely excited about
launching my upcoming line in
collaboration with H&M unfortunately
after seeing the disturbing image
yesterday my excitement over our global
campaign quickly evaporated outside at
this time our partnership needs to end
well oblivious oversight or not it's
truly sad and disturbing that 10:18 some
so racially and culturally insensitive
could pass by lies so many styles
photography creative marketing teams and
be deemed acceptable I can't allow for
my name and brand
with company that could let this happen
hope the situation will serve as a
wake-up call that hmm another companies
need yeah yeah I've just heard this to
me to me somebody who doesn't feel this
type of way it just easy has to do this
though cuz you're gonna get some
backlash if this comes out and then your
collab comes out where the fans are like
what the [ __ ] you support these rates
that bastard's a good point you would
probably lose more money if he write if
he wrote this out but they probably have
to people were still gonna go shop at
H&M next week I don't give it were just
sitting at home [ __ ] saying probably
won't affect ourselves right yeah I
would probably still buy because it's
cheap I would still buy cuz I don't
think the racist I think they're stupid
yeah I think they were smooth yeah let
me ask you this in would you I'm just
thinking off the top of my head or
anything so if I wore a hoodie or if I
was in an ad and I wear a hoodie is it a
white hoodie let's say it's uh let's say
it's an Under Armour hoodie cuz it'll go
with what I'm saying and what if it said
don't be the [ __ ] in the armor and I
was wearing it would you let that ad go
out would you not think twice about that
I would not let that go out I would not
let that I go out interesting I don't if
you didn't want to says super [ __ ] on
it I might think that that's fun because
if it had a name on the back what I
wouldn't let it go out what I would I
would buy one personally and honest with
you yeah we'd each have one what about
if you had a hoodie on and it said I'm
good at math or if I said of course I'm
gonna map there you go that's a really
good one not racist because it's it's a
positive thing it doesn't say anything
well a monkey is just it's just not good
for a human being to be what if I get
super capable they are very smart and we
did start wrong but what if what if Nike
to campaign with a black kid and his
shirt said of course I'm athletic yeah
oh yeah is that racist yeah it seems
like it would be a little too much sorry
what was it again I want to know this
one if Nike did a campaign with a black
kid or black
man is said of course I'm athletic races
are not fast strong yeah I mean no cuz
it's probably like a positive but it
might seem I mean the only people that
really get to cry to get to say what's
racist are people that have white that
aren't white yeah but I think it's gonna
start evening out a little bit more
where hopefully we get to a level where
everyone looks at each other or we
perceive that we all look at each other
the same logo so then we can you know
see race you know every of everybody
that is you know if somebody really is
racist cuz I mean I've felt racism
before from people it's like see you
know it's how you learn what it feels
like but is that racist if it's positive
yeah it's probably is racist right is
right you know of course I'm a surgeon
but it would be wouldn't be as great I
mean the math thing wouldn't be as
racist as the athletic thing there's a
reason all right wouldn't you the agree
or no if you if I said of course I'm
good at math a black guy wearing of
course I'm athletic right which one do
you feel is more racist um what unity
feels more offensive hmm
the black one you know what they're all
the same I don't know the of course but
it's also a pry it's like yeah [ __ ]
um I'm athletic but it's not true
right it's not true but in all they just
emphasize math more in their culture
right and them and also what agents are
[ __ ] I mean here's the thing some
ethnicities are so far in time it would
have with whatever little evidence we
might draw from here in America you know
which is probably pretty limited would
appear then better at some things or the
argument with that in those cultures in
those ghettos in those in those wards in
those poor low-income places are those
children that predominately happen to be
african-american are they pushed into
sports right because that's their only
you know that's what the one of their
avenues to get out of there to make
money
oh yeah as a white kid in certain
neighborhoods that maybe middle class
you know or maybe is poor but they're
not pushed so much on sports yeah so
that's why are we just assuming they're
better at sports so they're more
athletic and you know more explosive or
is it just they focus on it more the
same as the Chinese do when it comes to
math or you know just our brains are all
the same we've learned that right that's
one thing we know every humans brain is
the same yeah so since you were born if
your sole focus was to be the fastest
man on the planet and to get good at
soccer you probably be pretty [ __ ]
good
yeah if everyone around you the same way
it's this competitive nature we're all
trying to make to the league you're all
gonna be pretty [ __ ] good and
especially if I look around my
neighborhood and the only person that
anybody knows who's had success is in
two or three different avenues he's
gonna focus on that then and those are
your only choices and those are things
for survivors education is not the focus
right you're gonna focus more on sport
yeah yeah yeah because I think that
those are ones whether it's more of a
you know you can't have as much white
privilege in those type of environments
or as much European privilege or
whatever you want to call it you know
those are areas where you can get in and
you can make your mark no matter what
are easier so yeah I could imagine I
mean that's you know and it's got to be
tough and it's got to be unfortunate and
then it starts to become that probably
there's some black children out there or
poor white children that feel like the
only way that they can succeed that's
even cool is through sports or music
right so then that has to be a little
bit self too like unfortunate because
then they don't even want to try these
other avenues that are now available to
these are also told like this is how to
get out here this way you gonna do or
man make sure you're doing this or focus
on this right you know or it's not hip
it's not hip now in that culture to be
anything else then like if you're poor
it's not hip to be like oh I remember
growing up money but if I told some I
want to be a [ __ ] lawyer they're
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of me correct
you know cool it's just not cool so in
poor culture it's like it's not cool to
be anything other than athletic or a
musician career now so now that's like
focus yeah and then that then you [ __ ]
up because there's the only things
you're going for if you don't those
capabilities anymore and there's so much
more available to you now
like in India some of the best computer
programmers in the world or India yeah
in the
world there's some of the best they're
taking you know not taking jobs but they
have a ton of jobs they come over here
they do a great job me and my brother
talking about this you think they're
what what do you think they're so good
at cuz they put a focus on computer
programming yeah so now they have you
know how many people they have there
shitload so you're gonna get some people
you can learn and find up a sandwich
over there you know it's like but if
you're inside out that you know they
focus on schools and academics be like
God Chinese people always smart well in
their culture they're told they have to
do that yeah it's a smart white kid
they're smart black kids yeah it's a
smart friendly and smart Russians it
just depends what you're geared towards
yeah grow up and I think we're all the
same it's interesting fact that we all
the same brain man [ __ ] I'm gonna tell
my friends in ya go tell your friends
were all the same what else you got chin
what do you want more to really get feel
out of it all right call my [ __ ] up
your schedule too we've noticed gotta go
you're just some Chatty Cathy's yeah
it's a good show alright a kayaker in
Japan admitted to setting up his rival
by putting a banned substance in that
rivals drink before they race hilarious
and that guy got caught and he was
banned for life
the guy who put the other guy that got
slipped the supplement oh but the
substance can he prove that that guy put
the drink in there so check it out he
was this guy felt so guilty this is the
guy's face by the way he commits suicide
yeah he felt so guilty he admitted it to
the to the officials and now he's banned
for eight years from the kayaking sport
at least it's only eight years and that
guy's obviously you know he's redeemed
now the other guy's good to go type move
man Oh folks I would actually happen
people yeah put in the honor the shame
that he probably feels huh yeah because
Shane was pretty heavy I feel like in
his culture from the looks of him but
you're so guilty well the guy who was
falsely [ __ ] over though the way
steroids worked and those accusations
you know how many people heard about him
you know being screwed over a lot of
people just like oh he took steroids
he's [ __ ] to write it off he was in
the restaurants to talk about you know
it's not exact no no hold on
didn't you see the story like now
anyone kept a story the allegation right
when it comes out you're screwed forever
people what's that also here's a history
of like messing people's gear like
stealing stuff 51 it looks like a shifty
one I want to trust him he's like one of
those guys on the file one of those um
those Ultimate Fighter or something
things at cheats or something yeah yeah
yeah like a Junie browning or war
machine or some [ __ ] so it turns it boom
well brother you're at the Brahe improv
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday
and Sunday yep at the brain improv all
weekend I'll be in Jacksonville the
following weekend
I got Portland coming up I got the
helium in Portland I'm gonna be at
Harveys in Portland with the helium this
week yeah it seems cool yeah I've never
been in this place called Harvey's but
I'm excited nice man and then I'll be in
La Jolla and some other places you can
check it out on Theo van comm slashed or
boom - on 17t fat cake gets the year
Silvana remembered as usual man we're a
couple Chatty Cathy's when we get
together well it was nice out of really
nice time I'd appreciate a nice
conversation was I get more than anyone
this is fun man yes I didn't include you
that much in-game like oh yeah that's a
bummer we weren't trying to be sex I
wasn't trying to be sex no not at all
hashtag zero okay good the Thursday
tomorrow's you guys listen this Thursday
night I'm in Portland helium Thursday
one show Friday to show Saturday two
shows all those shows are almost sold
out good tea fat cake calm right now
four tickets and then the only other
show that's not sold out are we just
added another date January 31st economy
works downtown Denver the ferry first
one is sold out so we had a show on that
Wednesday night 31st and then on the
third and fourth I'm in st. Louis st.
Louis come and get it come and get it t
back a calm for tickets and then Brian
is in Nashville Zanies this weekend go
see my best comics in the world town
zannies nashville t fat k calm we love
you guys this is the fighter and the
vaughn we're out